[Music]
i have with me
david pakman he is a progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and tv program
the david pacman show and i wanted to
talk to david patman
he is a beta male 1
david pacman he is a beta
david pacman
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah
male 1 they think and act like a woman
they are emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but holy whoa
whoa jesse well we gotta
that's a lot that's a lot of people
agree with everything that's raw
abortion they think and act just like a
woman a beta male dog
but another baby doesn't because he's a
logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pakman
he is a baby
david patman he is a
man the lady david pacman
he is a baby
david patman he is
[Music]
david you're not here to communicate i
really appreciate you coming out i'm
going to let you go it's a waste of time
to talk to you
we're not communicating you're actually
like because you're asking
bizarre questions you're actually like
an idiot and you're wasting my time
i appreciate that coming all right
goodbye
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
and what have you today i'm pleased to
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the
china virus that will save countless all
right okay no time for more of that
stuff
wow a very very special day and a very
very special introduction
that's hot off the presses thanks to
producer pat
who put that together and basically my
instructions were put together
the most cringe-worthy compilation you
possibly can
to then play before the stream
with uh some of these great songs from
joseph woodward of course
plasma the song of the summer as well as
david pakman is a beta male we also have
other songs which we may have later we
we actually also have a music video
which was sent to me
which maybe we will look at later it'll
depend on sort of how the evening goes
we do have about a half hour
until the start of the second and final
debate between
who is debating tonight i guess it's
trump and biden
and donald trump um about an hour and a
half ago
trotting out a very important guest
at the nashville tennessee location for
the debate and it was some guy with some
claims about biden i mean it's just a
complete
non-starter remember the guy who brought
us the hunter biden story
uh ended up with his hand in his pants
in front of six cameras as
borat ran in so i don't know that that's
necessarily the guy
uh that we want to be listening to about
what's going on
with our politics um okay we're i don't
even know where to start today
i hope people have voted uh
if you follow me on instagram which you
should
you would already know that i very very
strongly voted
uh over the weekend here is me inserting
my ballot
into an official city of boston dropbox
and then walking off screen
um and i will be i actually forgot to
track my ballot but i will track it soon
and see if it's been delivered i hope
all of you voted as well
and then just as an example of some of
the other hijinks
that sometimes happens on my uh
instagram here is a little bit of a
voicemail that i received the other day
just to give you a sense of what i get
little argentine israeli troll and
why aren't you wearing a mask you do
this live stream all your shows i never
see you
you wear a [ __ ] mask uh uh
when you're doing your live streams you
know so why are you wearing goggles why
why don't you have a headphone i should
wear mask a mask
and goggles just sitting in the studio
by myself that seemed just to be extra
safe
and a necklace wait all that money you
make you don't have an old gold necklace
how come you don't have a gold tooth
like uh [ __ ]
uh flavor flav you know
you're a hypocrite if you can complain
about people taking their masks off no
hypocrisy here i don't think that people
broadcasting in studios by themselves
should wear masks so don't uh just
certainly don't don't misunderstand
absolutely no hypocrisy whatsoever but
anyway
you know each day we get about 100
voicemails and sometimes they're as
crazy as that so we will we will keep an
eye on that
uh as we await the start of what is
going to be it's both the second but
also the final debate because donald
trump
refused to do the second debate remote
despite having coronavirus and then
things just got you know completely and
totally crazy
uh i see a lot of people apparently
noticing that
something crazy happened on our youtube
channel today yeah i was just looking
somehow we we already have 2 000 new
subscribers today on the youtube channel
and it's the best day we've ever had on
youtube from the standpoint of views
and we've only just started the stream
so we are
uh apparently setting setting a new high
bar today as far as youtube is concerned
and that's very very exciting
let me do where to even start um
hold on what did i have uh oh oh oh
so um pete boudage many of you remember
him from such
such episodes as the democratic primary
and mayor of south bend indiana
he has been just dropping bombs on fox
news
and they continue giving him these bs
questions
and he just dismantles them this was
earlier today take a look at this
it's not even clear what he's claiming
adds up to uh they're just kind of
saying oh they're they're questions
let's ask if they want to make this
about the business deals
of a government official let's talk
about the president of the united states
having a secret chinese bank account
that's not like
you know something somebody said that
used to work with somebody related to
the president and even that's a matter
of documented fact
and they won't even tell us what bank
it's with does that bother americans
i'm pretty sure it bothers americans a
lot more than what they're trying to
whip up for the last 12 days of this
election season
yeah and every every time he does this
the uh the fox
news hosts don't know what on earth to
do let me see if i can find the pete
bootage edge
prostitute clip and it's not like root
like the rudy giuliani stuff this is
something else
uh this is a real let me see if i can
just find it here
um booted judge hold on a second
was it uh i guess it's with steve ducey
maybe
um no no actually it was with it was
actually with martha mccallum
let me see if i can find this oh yeah
here it is insight into
what she might say to justify why she
was for medicare for all
then and is not for it now for example
well there's a classic parlor game of
trying to find a little bit of daylight
between running mates and if people want
to play that game we could look into why
an evangelical christian like mike pence
wants to be on a ticket with the
president caught with a porn star or
how he feels about the immigration
policy that he called
unconstitutional before he decided to
team up with donald trump
folks want to play that game we could do
it all night but i think what most
americans want to hear about is
are our families going to be better
protected than they have been
right this president who's failed to
secure america
in the face of one of the most dangerous
things ever to happen to our country
yeah they had to move on from that one
not not not going particularly well
there as
as you could imagine so anyway pete's
doing really well
it doesn't mean that my favorite
candidate is pete or anything like that
it's just he's been doing really well at
just dropping the hammer on fox news
very very regularly okay let me see what
else i have here
um oh a trump supporter has been
arrested
for requesting an absentee ballot for
their dead mother
so as usual the very oh it's daniel
marins i know daniel that's interesting
he's a good guy
um it's it's as usual you know
republicans say in-person voter fraud
it's it's
rampant it's republicans arrested for
voter fraud trying to test the system
turns out the system works okay
um and then now trump supporter arrested
for requesting an absentee ballot for
their dead mother
we had a q anon trumpist
arrested last week because uh he
happened to be a postal carrier
and had like eight bags of mail sitting
on the curb ready to be disposed of when
the trash truck
came by it's just absolutely ridiculous
and then i don't know if you heard this
is just like an insult to injury thing
uh trump's twitter was accessed last
week
by a security expert what's really funny
about security expert is
he just guessed the password maga2020
exclamation point
so it's like i don't deny that he was an
expert but at the same time does that
require that much expertise to try the
password maga 2020 exclamation point and
it happens to be donald trump um
so uh oh is that did that not actually
happen are people saying that didn't
happen
is this was this misreported
i haven't seen any update uh i believe
that that's a real story
yeah updated with twitter comment and
corrected the name of the publication
which first published the news
um
trump says nobody got hacked but forgot
his hotel chain was hacked twice
my god uh okay so anyway those those are
a couple um
a couple stories that have cropped up
lately uh
if you're interested i will be live
tweeting
during the debate and you will actually
see me compose my tweets
and uh you can follow those there if you
would like
i'm d pacman on twitter uh donald trump
by the way earlier today releasing
his 60 minutes interview an unusual move
to release the 60 minutes interview
before 60 minutes
for me this was the most memorable
memorable moment and as many of you know
i have a similar type of glass
and i will often drink the exact same
way
so anyway that was uh that was a moment
earlier
and then i mean i guess um
i guess just to be thorough i should
show you
uh this was rudy giuliani in the
forthcoming
borat sequel which goes live i i
actually am wondering if amazon prime
video will crash
when this goes live i they said tomorrow
i don't know if that means midnight
tonight it goes live
or um or or at some point tomorrow
morning i don't know but i am certainly
going to be going to be watching that so
a lot going on my friends
really a lot of different things going
on okay let me just start
i'm already falling behind on a lot of
different things so let's just do
a couple different oh let's see what's
coming in from super chats i'm just
going to scroll
through some of these super chats
chakaseki who we learned yesterday is
actually a physician
chakuseki is a radiologist says how
severe will
the orange jackass oh lantern's
implosion be
during mute apocalypse tonight will he
leave behind
a mango singularity i think so i think
that that absolutely will happen
joseph dinzie's asking about aoc
offering to speak and then backing down
for an event honoring yitzhak rabin
i i didn't hear about that i wouldn't be
able to comment
darwin asks are the mask wearing
supporters in the background of trump
rallies paid actors
i can't rationalize a person who would
support trump but also wear a mask at an
event no matter how hard
i try i think they're told you have to
wear a mask if you want to be up on
stage
i think that's the uh i think that's the
deal lauren
says i view donating to a congress
person outside my district as equivalent
to foreign interference by say turkey i
oppose both do you agree
no i mean listen if if you don't have to
um if you don't have to live in the
district you represent
i don't think you should have to live in
the district in order to donate
uh to that candidate um so i don't agree
lawrence with total peace and love
milo says make sure to vote for joseph
kenneth destiny biden jr ii on november
3rd
yeah if you're just joining us i did
vote on saturday here is video of me
voting
um i would love to hear from you could
be via super chat or youtube
or twitch sub message or however really
um
did you vote already reportedly over 40
million people have already voted
we're only expecting 125 to 130 million
people
total to vote and 45 have already voted
if you can imagine that
that's insane but of course it's not a
normal year
it's because so many people are being
encouraged to vote early because of
the pandemic um okay so that's that let
me know
how you are doing as far as as far as
voting is concerned
zack says david vaccine news is very
promising wide rollout beginning of next
year hopefully under a new president
let's hope so
brooks says thanks for the streams
you're awesome you've said trump's
claims that
biden will raise taxes four times as
mathematically impossible can you
explain
yeah so like for example if the top tax
bracket is 35 percent
times four that's 140 percent how can
you have a hundred and forty percent tax
bracket
just doesn't make any sense it's
impossible for every dollar you make you
owe a dollar and 40 cents
that's that's ridiculous luke says
dropping a super chat and bouncing
prepare to wat for her to watch debates
without commentary but keep up the great
work thank you
richard hutching says are you co-hosting
this video with borat or his daughter
yes yes emmanuel kant says so ironic how
rudy
gullini was on crowder's show the other
day making fun of joe's son for using
drugs peak cringe
yeah it's it's it's horrible sunder
says go vote you americans angel
says i found your channel just after
covet hit the us and i want to thank you
for really educating me on politics
and the progressive movement excellent
excellent what would it take for trump
to rage quit mid-debate
i don't know i i don't know about you
guys but i think
that trump is going to try to interrupt
biden
even despite the muted microphone and
um i don't know what the reaction is
going to be from from the crowd
uh or or from just voters but uh
whoa something is happening here but i
do think trump is not going to be able
to resist i really don't particularly
after barack obama brutally destroyed
him yesterday i think that trump is not
going to be able to take it
okay i do want to thank some people
uh who have signed up on my website i'm
gonna try not to fall behind
we have a very modest goal of 25 new
members as you can see right above my
head we had 380 during the first debate
the goal today is only 25.
mark anthony gibbons is new member
number one
daniel rhodes is new member number two
also want to say thanks to
steve cimino who is number three today
jen osman is new member number four
monica thoreau is new member number five
spencer hadfield
is number six grace lord is number seven
and daniel
blankie is new member number eight i
appreciate that
and um yeah all the info about that is
is on my website
info is right up there at joinpakman.com
other super chats that continue to come
in actually no i don't want to ignore
our beautiful twitch viewers so let me
see what people are saying there
dire dragon has subscribed and says keep
up the great work david
astro dastro subscribes and says bonsoir
mesa me
good evening my friends uji lost has
subscribed
uh amber gifford schmevel left social
snuggles
castraticron mica nobi
oh my god i'm having a lot of trouble
pronouncing a lot of these today
but we'll do the uh i'll i'll do the
best i can
other super chats walla is misa's news
blooper they called her
amy boney carrot made me smile for a bit
that can't be true
amy bony cara did that really happen
that sounds hilarious carmen edwards
says i hope
not to see a rendition of two barking
dogs thanks for your interpretation my
pleasure
johnny says if it wasn't for your debate
live stream i'd skip the whole thing
for the newest episode of drag race
holland that's now a show not a show
i've seen
chakaseki is demanding shout outs for
box
spencer peter and enrique from tufts
they are the original dream team love it
love it love it love it uh let's see
what other questions
are there connor says david i'm on a
plane from boston for the first time
trying to stream this on board
visiting my sister during her first
semester at harvard to help fight
homesickness what's the go-to michael's
deli order for
my dad and i oh yeah listen i would if
you go to michael's deli
my go-to is just pastrami on
pumpernickel with mustard
call me old-fashioned you know but i i
go with the pumpernickel
bread rather than the rye a lot of
people prefer the rye but go with the
pastrami could also do corned beef
and um if you really want to get crazy
throw throw some pickles on there and
tell
if you do go to michael's deli always
tell steve that the david pakman show
sent you i get nothing for it uh but
it's funny every when i go in and he
says two more people came in
uh yeah okay i guess that's it on that
oliver says david i hope biden is
feeling as verbose as i am tonight and
can someone please deep fake david into
a borat gif we could use a laugh
that is a great request deep fake me
into
a borat gif i think that would be great
by the way i want to debut something for
you guys um
our friend and composer joseph woodward
as you may
recall put together this song recently
hold on a second here this song
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer okay anyway so the
point is
then after that we actually
i apologize i just i just that was crazy
what i was saying was our friend kyle
hopper
um our friend kyle hopper oh hold on did
we just get raided
i want to make sure i'm aware of that uh
i'm not seeing the raid did we get
raided i didn't see it okay
our friend uh our friend kyle hopper put
together a music video with the clips
from that song okay so take a look at
this
this was the awkward moment before my
interview with jessie lee peterson
started and it's just this is
beautifully beautifully done
here we go oh there's the raid from levy
rosman love it
welcome guys we've got a big night ahead
of us
new music video very very hot with me
david pakman
he is a progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and tv program
yeah the david pacman show this is
really well done
and i wanted to talk to david patman he
is a baby
david patman he is
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah male
1
they think and act like a woman they are
emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but holy whoa
whoa jesse well we gotta
that's a lot that's a lot of people
agree with everything that's raw
abortion they think and act just like a
woman a beta male died
but another baby doesn't because he's a
logical
thinking and they're controlled by the
darkness of david patman
right deep faith
[Music]
okay actually i'm gonna stop it because
we may be getting into some like dmca
stuff i don't i don't exactly know
what's going on with uh with some of
these platforms we're on but in any case
uh very very hot new track and the the
music video um
just as hot and people are people are
going
people are going completely crazy okay
uh we are standing by
just 14 minutes from the start of the
second and final
presidential debate between donald trump
uh
and joe biden and it is going to be
absolutely wild we are taking
memberships right now including brandon
sharp who's new member number nine
david mcginnis who's new member number
10 crystal smiley is number 11.
michael bland is number 12. kyle
montgomery is 13
and franziska danteva
is new member number 14 right now on my
website
we will uh i mean i might as well you
know we're actually we're going for a
hundred today
and the phone lines will open via
discord
potentially after the debate uh
davidpakman.com
discord is the new david pakman show
official discord i
invite you to join it if you would like
um if indeed we do take phone calls
after the debate it will be happening
via discord
so just letting you know about that just
so everybody knows the plan
okay um a couple of other messages
coming in
through twitch emerald ideas says thanks
for keeping people informed
i appreciate that we got the very strong
raid from
levy gotham chess rosman and i hope
uh you all will will stick around um
deca dentista says best wishes from
germany
from a german in la voting for biden
uh and individualism killed the cat
says let's do this with a uh with a
twitch prime sub so people very very
excited and and
wow i can tell people are wound up
because this is a big night
this is a very very big night okay other
super chats here
philip liked the intro video i did see
the picture josh of mitch mcconnell's
hand
i don't know what that is it seems like
some kind of bruising
maybe from an iv his hands were black
it was it was very odd but it seems like
a health issue clearly clearly i don't
know i don't know what else to say
um do i agree with bernie sanders when
he says biden would be the most
progressive president since
fdr yeah i i've been saying that since
before bernie's been saying it bernie
got that from me
just kidding uh but i have been saying
that for months
delilah rose says biden 2020 by dawn
2020 daniel says
are there new informations about the
hunter biden
is it disproven they now say hunter's
business partner said it's legit
greetings from south korea uh you know
if anything broke in the last hour
i haven't seen it um but
uh i i will look into that i will look
into that
by the way if anybody's having a problem
with the stream i believe there was a
hiccup
just refresh well i guess if the
stream's frozen you wouldn't hear me
saying refresh
but tell people in chat uh just to
refresh if that's the case i think
that'll be fine
fred trump says think the new
developments with hunter biden's
business partner will have an impact
ps i hate my son again i i'm not i'm not
exactly sure yet
i'm not exactly sure um tim says i voted
today could you all up the clip quality
on the videos yeah we're working on that
we're working on that
super oprah says hi from canada my son
and i love your channel we watch you
every day
thanks for your great insight can't stop
laughing at rudy's rowdy rooster
yeah uh herman cain's debate's still
active
a retro something about major league
soccer don't know anything about that
mike says do i ever think that poor and
toxic mental health plays a large part
in how and why right-wing sycophants can
still back trump
i do i do think so yeah
um thoughts on warren and mayor pete in
the cabinet i think both would be
interesting
i'm less clear on what mayor pete's role
would be i could see elizabeth warren as
secretary of education
i could see her as a treasury secretary
there's really a lot of roles that seem
natural for elizabeth warren
uh you know you could find something for
pete although it's less
obvious to me what it would be
hud some people are saying yeah i'm not
sure
i'm not sure alec van der pol says as a
dutch american i'm itching to get back
to the netherlands to visit friends and
family what are your top three countries
to visit once it's safe
honestly so i was i was scheduled to go
to a number of different places
including japan
this this year or was it last year no
this year yeah this is this year is the
pandemic
and honestly right now after the
pandemic i'm looking to go back to
places i've been
which i just already know and like and
it's just easy
and just to kind of go back somewhere i
know i will like so i'm looking at a
trip that will include
um potentially going back to paris would
like to get back to israel soon
and um yeah there's there's a lot of
places a lot a lot of places on my list
let's see here um super chats are just
flying in i'm going to get away from
super chats
just for a moment a few things just to
let everybody know kind of the the plan
for tonight uh the debate scheduled for
90 minutes starting
eight minutes from now my thought is
after the debate maybe if we get to this
subscriber and patron goal
i'll open up phone lines and if that
happens
it's going to be via the uh discord
which is davidpakman.com discord
d-i-s-c-o-r-d
and the the audio quality is beautiful
now i already see people in the discord
in the
audio lobby you're going to be waiting
for hours minimum
because we're not we're not going to
calls at least until the end of the
debate
but if you want to hang out in the audio
lobby the entire time
uh i won't stop you but just sort of as
a
as a heads up um in terms of i
i will be live tweeting you can follow
that you know
on twitter whoa rudy with his hand in
his pants out of nowhere sorry about
that guys let me close that out
that's that's for later um i'm d pacman
on twitter i'll be composing my tweets
in front of you guys
uh so there will be full disclosure and
um
by the way i don't know how many of you
saw the 60 minutes interview but really
really interesting ways
of drinking water by donald trump but
yeah so so that will be going on
and then i actually am leaning towards
carrying the pbs stream i actually heard
that c-span may not be the safest
stream although typically it is uh but
we'll
you know we'll monitor that as we can
and hopefully we won't experience any
kind of shutdown whatsoever
okay um let me just scroll up a little i
i'm going to try to get to a lot of
super chats today but they're coming in
so
fast and furious that it is going to be
tough to get all of them but i'm going
to do
the the best i can andrew's watching
from ireland says should be a
fascinating night will trump dive across
the stage to wine into biden's mike
that i don't know but i expect a lot of
whining a lot a lot of whining from
donald trump tonight
uh john wants to know if beta pacman
will start an only fan's account
no i have a cameo i am not on only fans
and if there is any account
on only fans claiming to be me it is not
really me
all right so please don't fall for it
and certainly don't send anybody
money on on only fans thinking that it's
me
let's see what else we have beth says
what makes you the most nervous about
biden tonight
just that he could get thrown off by
trump's belligerence again i mean
it clearly was throwing him off to some
degree last debate
and also you know that whether the
moderator can or can't control
the debate is always a question mark in
any debate in any debate
what else do we have vida risa says
empanadas
eating some empanadas ready for the
disaster shouting and lies from the
idiot
these four years have felt like a decade
keep up the good work always watch your
videos
chris is asking if this is an among us
stream you know i still have no idea
what among us really is i still don't
know like i know it's a game and i've
seen a screenshot of it
i have no idea is that crazy or what
those who those of us who watch on
twitch on data can't because the stream
quality setting can't be lowered yeah i
can't control that
people often um attack me for having
limit you know just one or or limited uh
stream qualities is this melania on uh
on twitch i can't control i'm only an
affiliate not a partner
so let's see we've got tiffany trump
here i think that was eric here is
melania
wearing a mask remember that the trump
family removed their masks during the
first debate
the debate organizers from the
commission on presidential debates said
that they would be asked to leave
if they remove their masks again so
we will see if that happens and
presumably unless i missed it we are
waiting for
dr jill biden as well listen i i think
this is as good a time
maybe as ever just to mention i would
really love it it would mean a lot to me
if you supported this stream and all of
our other work by grabbing
a membership on my website
joinpacman.com
as you can see we've got about close to
forty thousand thirty thirty seven
thousand people watching right now
across our different platforms
our goal is only 100 website members we
had about 380 during the first debate
uh i would love it if you signed up and
as i've mentioned
i am committing to opening the phone
lines if we do get to that
number 100 it's really cheap really
really cheap and if you use the coupon
code
2020 now which is above my head in blue
text
you save 66 so we're not talking a lot
about a lot of money
the memberships allow us to sort of
build revenue we can count on you know
youtube revenue is very irregular twitch
revenue is very irregular
when you sign up on our website you're
sort of going directly to the source
uh cutting out the middleman and i would
uh
love it love it love it if you did that
a couple people who just signed up
i will thank and i will try to thank
everybody mandy rivers is new member
number 15.
mark blunt is number 16
marcia shamness is number 17.
kyle riquelme is number 18.
judson salomon is number 19.
stephanie rodriguez is number 20. very
much appreciate it and i'll keep
throwing in as many
as many thank yous as i can uh
the website should not crash no the web
website should we have had issues where
a lot of people try to get a membership
and the website has crashed
but we've uh we've quadrupled the
resources
on the website and we should not have
any kind of problem with that whatsoever
all right we are down to the last six
and a half minutes this is moderator
kristen welker here
let's listen to see if she's addressing
the crowd uh out loud
i'm thankful that you are feeling better
i want to welcome the boston family dr
jill biden thank you all
for being here tonight we are so excited
we're looking forward to
a really robust discussion and the only
thing i would reiterate are the cpd
guidelines that when the candidates are
talking please hold any
applause or any other reactions except
of course when they walk out
make sure you cheer and loud and
applause so that everyone can hear you
yeah thank you for having me this is
really the honor of a lifetime i am
gonna
sit down and just get organized and get
settled and
the show will start very soon thank you
for being here
all right so what is effectively the
standard
admonishment from debate moderators to
the crowd
to uh keep it down essentially keep it
down to the extent that they
are able and uh we will see if even
donald trump can keep it down
when it is joe biden's turn to speak um
let's see here crazy cat lady says david
uh love your show did you pay more in
taxes last year than trump did oh my god
you should see what i paid in taxes you
should see what i paid in taxes
um illegal in some states
uh solange gregory says david i need to
call in and speak to you about miami
cops the whole face mask thing is
nothing they are a gang they aren't cops
okay i don't know about that
but i'm always interested in hearing
from viewers
uh as as always um
bring me a pillow has grabbed a twitch
prime sub
master chess dojo has subscribed and
says
thank you david um people on twitch very
very excited
uh as i mentioned earlier they're uh
we are making we are making twitch a
very
strong part of our 2021 plan we've
already started
uh sort of brainstorming some of our
2021 ideas
and twitch is going to be a big part of
that also a few things pending on twitch
i am um organizing a chess tournament on
chess.com for after the
election uh regardless of the of the
results i think we will all need a
little something not not politics
related and i will be co-hosting that
with levy rosman the international chess
master gm benjamin feingold may be
playing in that tournament who
will also be giving me a lesson soon so
we've got a lot of cool and different
things going on
and of course to keep up with any of it
it costs nothing
just follow me if you're watching on
twitch
or hit the subscribe button if you were
watching on youtube this stuff is free
last debate the youtube viewers
broke the subscribe button i know you
it's like how could that happen
right so many people subscribed to our
youtube channel last debate
that youtube triggered a spam
defense mechanism where it took them a
week
to verify like th this is more
subscribers
in a short period of time than anybody
normally gets we need to verify that
some kind of
bots aren't being used which i know
there were very ugly allegations about
at one point from sam cedar but you
literally you broke the subscribe button
during during the first debate which is
absolutely insane
uh so anyway long story short make sure
to follow like and subscribe regardless
of where it is that you are
that you are watching uh people a lot of
people asking about various drinking
games kevin's saying do we drink every
time he says radical left or something
like that
you know the safest drinking game is to
drink whenever trump tells
the truth you'll remain uh stone cold
sober
for the entire debate in your groove
asking via twitch prime will you stream
election night yes
yes uh that may be the last big stream
of the show as many people are emailing
me
the show is circling the drain that's a
frequent refrain from many of the
hatreds
and uh i guess if that's the case
election night may be the last
the absolutely last stream i ever do
that would be very very sad
wouldn't it karen has her seatbelt on
and a bowl of popcorn handy
because we are in for a wild ride
i'll make sure we've got audio here
actually let's see
we've got uh okay yeah tonight's
moderator is kristin welker of nbc news
to her in a moment but joining me
tonight okay so we'll stay
over here i guess for the time being we
don't want to miss it fred says the show
will start soon what an appropriate
choice of words by the moderator
denver says i could not handle the
psychic trauma of these debates without
you david and that is not even a joke
thank you democratic brotherhood says
david your channel inspired me to choose
to pursue a degree
in international politics and
criminology i'm in my second year hope
to do what you do
beautiful love it love it very much
appreciate that
thanks to zach prakowski for the five
gifted subs over on twitch
and we are just moments from the start
of this second
and final debate a couple other thank
yous to get in
karen wilkie jedoyne is new member
number 21 today
sean mcdonald is new member number 22 at
joinedpakman.com
let's keep it going my friends the phone
lines will open
at a hundred uh medea beasley
new member number 23 and it seems as
though
kristen welker is very close to ready
uh to start this evening's event
do i think we'll get an appearance from
the most popular fly in the country i
actually think we will see a locust
today and it will be a very very bad
omen
uh it will be in trump's water that's
gonna be scary
scary stuff ryan says just join david
love the show
ken says the borat movie is up early on
prime okay well
listen don't leave don't please don't
leave to watch the borap movie this is
live the borat movie is not live
uh i will i will have to check it out a
little bit later today
and i think it's going to be very very
interesting
um
what else do we have a lot of spanish
messages here
siba piazz says saludos
belmont university in nashville
tennessee all right let's switch
over now to pbs has promised to remain
silent
no cheers booze or other interruptions
here we go except
right now as we welcome to the stage
former vice president joe biden
and president donald j trump let's see
if there's any greeting between the two
candidates trump going very very hard
against biden recently
they're not showing it for whatever
reason uh let's see here
no acknowledgement thus far
interesting a little bit of something i
want to say a very good
evening to both of you this debate will
cover six
major topics at the beginning of each
section each candidate will have two
minutes uninterrupted
to answer my first question the debate
commission will then turn on
their microphone only when it is their
turn to answer
right the commission will turn it off
exactly when the two minutes have
expired
after that both microphones will remain
on but on behalf of the voters i'm going
to ask you to please speak one at a time
the goal is for you to hear each other
and for the american people
not trump's goal word of what you both
have to say
and so with that if you're ready let's
start
and we will begin with the fight against
the coronavirus president trump the
first question is for you
the country is heading into a dangerous
new phase more than 40 thousand
americans are in the hospital tonight
with covid
including record numbers here in
tennessee and since the two of you last
shared a stage sixteen thousand
americans have died from covid
so please be specific how would you lead
the country during this
next stage of the coronavirus crisis two
minutes uninterrupted
so as you know 2.2 million
people modeled out were expected to die
we closed up the greatest economy in the
world in order to fight
this horrible disease they came from
china it's a worldwide pandemic it's all
over the world you see the spikes in
europe and
many other places right now if you
notice the
mortality rate is down trump almost
brown tonight rather than orange while
not answering rate is way down and much
lower than almost any other country
and we're fighting it and we're fighting
it hard there is a spike there was a
spike in florida and
it's now gone there was a very big spike
in texas
it's now gone there was a very big spike
in arizona it's now gone
and there are some spikes and surges and
other places they will soon be gone
we have a vaccine that's coming it's
ready it's
going to be announced within weeks and
it's going to be delivered we have
operation warp speed which is the
military is going to distribute the
vaccine
i can tell you from personal experience
that
i was in the hospital i had it and i got
better and i will tell you that
i had something that they gave me a
therapeutic
i guess they would call it some people
could say was a cure it wasn't but
uh i was in for a short period of time
and i got better very fast or i wouldn't
be here tonight
so what would he do say i'm immune
whether it's four months or a lifetime
nobody's been able to say that but
i'm immune uh more and more people are
getting better so you would do what a
problem that's a worldwide problem this
is a worldwide problem
but i've been congratulated by the heads
of many countries on what we've been
able to do
with the if you if you take a look at
what we've done in terms of
goggles and masks and gowns and
everything else
and in particular ventilators we're now
making ventilators
all over the world thousands and
thousands a month distributing them
all over the world it will go away and
as i say
we're rounding the turn we're rounding
the corner it's going away
okay former vice president biden to you
how would you lead the country out of
this crisis
you have two minutes uninterrupted 220
000 americans dead
if you hear nothing else i say tonight
hear this
anyone is responsible for not taking
control
in fact not saying i'm i take no
responsibility initially
anyone who's responsible for that many
deaths should not remain as president of
the united states of america
we're in a situation where there are a
thousand deaths
a day now a thousand deaths a day and
there are over
70 000 new cases per day
compared to what's going on in europe
as the new england medical journal said
they're starting from a very
low rate we're starting from a very high
rate
the expectation is we'll have another
200 000 americans dead
be timed between now and the end of the
year if we just wore
these masks the president's own advisers
have told them
we could save a hundred thousand lives
and we're in a circumstance where the
president thus far and still has
no plan no comprehensive plan
what i would do is make but he is immune
to everyone encouraged to wear a mask
all the time i would make sure we move
in the direction of rapid testing
investing in rapid testing i would make
sure that we
set up national standards as to how to
open up schools and open up businesses
so they can be safe
and give them the wherewithal the
financial resources to be able to do
that
we're in a situation now where the new
england medical journal one of the
serious most serious journals in the
in the whole world said for the first
time ever
that this the way this president has
responded to this crisis
has been absolutely tragic and so folks
i will trump nice and quiet this i will
make sure we have a plan
president trump i'd like to follow up
with you and your comments you talked
about taking a therapeutic i assume
you're referencing
regeneron you also said a vaccine will
be coming within weeks
yes is that a guarantee is no it's not a
guarantee but it will be by the end of
the year but i think he's been saying it
for months so of course it's not a
guarantee i think within a matter of
weeks
and it will be distributed very quickly
can you tell us which companies
uh johnson johnson is doing very well
moderner is doing very well
is doing very well and we have numerous
others then we also have others that
we're working on very closely with other
countries in particular europe
let me follow up with you because this
is new information you have said a
vaccine is coming soon within weeks now
your own officials say
it could take well into 2021 at the
earliest for enough americans to get
vaccinated
and even then they say the country will
be wearing masks and distancing
into 2022. is your timeline realistic
no i think my timeline is going to be
more accurate i don't know that they're
counting on the military the way i do
but we have our generals lined up one in
particular that's the
head of logistics one general is a very
easy distribution for him he's ready to
go as soon as we have the vaccine
and we expect to have a hundred million
vials as soon as we have the vaccine
he's ready to go vice president biden
your reaction and just 40
percent of americans say they would
definitely agree to take a coronavirus
vaccine
if it was approved by the government
what steps would you take to give
americans
confidence in a vaccine if it were
approved make sure it's totally
transparent have the scientists the
world see it
know it look at it go through all the
processes and by the way
he's this is the same fellow told you
this is going to end by easter last time
who told you that don't worry we're
going to end this by the summer we're
about to go into a dark winter
a dark winter and he has no clear plan
and there's no prospect
that there's going to be a vaccine
available for the majority of the
american people before the middle of
next year
president trump your reaction he says
you have no plans to have a dark winter
and at all we're opening up our country
1000 people died
and understand the disease which we
didn't at the beginning
when i closed and banned china from
coming in heavily infected and then
ultimately europe
but china was in january months later he
was saying i was xenophobic i did it too
soon now he's saying oh
i should have uh i should have you know
moved quicker but he didn't move quicker
he was months behind
he's not president many months behind me
and frankly
he ran the h1 n1 swine flu
and it was a total disaster far less
lethal 66 67
approval on swine flu had that had this
kind of
numbers 700 000 people would be dead
right now
but it was a far less lethal the death
rate of a different
virus a long time ago were different who
ran that for him
who as you know was his uh chief of
staff
said it was catastrophic it was horrible
we didn't know what we were doing now he
comes up and he tells us how to do this
also everything that he said about the
way every single move that he said we
should make
that's what we've done we've done all of
it but he was way behind us
vice president biden your response my
response is he is xenophobic but not
because he shut down
access from china beautiful after 40
countries had already done that
in addition to that what he did he made
sure in china
trying to get to wuhan to determine what
exactly the source was what did the
president say in january
he said no he said this is he's being
transparent
the president of china is being
transparent we owe more debt of
gratitude we ought to we have to thank
him
and and then what happened was we
started talking about using the defense
act
to make sure we go out and get whatever
is needed out there to protect people
and again i go back to this he had
nothing he did virtually nothing
and then he gets out of the hospital and
he talks about
where this is oh don't worry it's all
going to be over soon come on
there's not another serious scientist in
the world who thinks it's going to be
over soon
come on man over soon i say we're
learning to live with it we have no
choice we can't lock ourselves up in a
basement like
joe does he has the he has the ability
to lock himself
up i don't know he's obviously made a
lot of money someplace but he has this
living in a basement people can't do
that by the way i
as the president couldn't do that i'd
love to put myself in the basement or in
a beautiful room in the white house
and go away for a year and a half until
it disappears he would can't do that
and kirsten every every meeting i had
every meeting i had and i'd meet a lot
of families including gold star families
and military families
every meeting i had and i had to meet
them i had to it would be horrible to
have cancelled everything
i said you know this is dangerous i
think this is where he claims he got the
virus from a gold star family i learned
a lot
i learned a lot great doctors great
hospitals
and now i recovered 99.9
of young people recover 99
of people recover we have to recover we
can't close up our nature we have to
open our school
and we can't close up our nation or
you're not going to have a nation things
are open people just aren't going out i
said young people
can get sick with covet 19 and can pass
it vice president biden i want to talk
broadly about
strategy though you respond to that 30
seconds please again i have a question
no number one
he says that we're uh you know we're
learning to live with it
people are learning to die with it you
folks home will have an empty chair at
the kitchen table this morning
that man or wife going to bed tonight
and reaching over to try to touch their
out of habit where their wife or husband
was is gone
learning to live with it come on this is
not good for trump
because he has never said he said it's
dangerous
when's the last time is it really
dangerous still are we dangerous you
tell the people it's dangerous now what
should they do about the danger
and you say i take no responsibility let
me talk about your
excuse me i take it i take full
responsibility for what
it's not my fault that it came here it's
china's fault and you know what it's not
joe's fault he takes full responsibility
it's just not his fault china's fault
they kept it from going into the rest of
china for them
but they didn't keep it from coming out
to the world including europe and
ourselves
vice president biden the fact is that
when we knew it was coming
when it hit what happened what did the
president say
he said don't worry it's going to go
away be gone by easter don't worry the
warm weather don't worry maybe inject
bleach he said he was kidding when he
said that a lot of people thought it was
serious
injections of things the president said
even today
he thinks we are in control we're about
to lose 200 000 more people
president trump look perhaps just to
finish this
i was kidding on that but just to finish
this
when i closed he said i shouldn't have
closed
and that went on for months what nancy
pelosi said the same thing she was
dancing on the streets in chinatown in
san francisco
low energy but when i closed he said
this is a terrible thing you xenophobic
i think he called me racist even
and because i was closing it to china
now he says i should have closed it
earlier
it just joe it doesn't i didn't say
either of those things you certainly did
i talked about a xenophobia in a
different context it wasn't about
closing the border to chinese coming to
the united states all right i want to
talk about both of your different
strategies to handle i thought i
is that do you want to respond to that
quickly vice president okay
no i don't want to respond or no i don't
think mr vice president you suggested
you would support new shutdowns if
scientists
recommended it what do you say to
americans who are fearful that the cost
of shutdowns the impact on the economy
the higher rates of hunger depression
domestic and substance abuse
outweighs the risk of exposure to the
virus what i would say is i'm going to
shut down the virus not the country
it's his ineptitude the cause that
caused the country to have to shut down
and start getting triggered
why businesses have gone under why
schools are closed why so many people
have lost their
living and why they're concerned those
other concerns are real
that's why he should have been instead
of in a sand trap in this golf course he
should have been negotiating beautiful
nancy pelosi
and the rest of the democrats and
republicans about what to do about
the acts they were passing for billions
of dollars to make sure people had the
capacity
but you haven't ruled out more shutdowns
well no i i'm not shutting you down
tonight but there are
look the need standard the standard is
if you have a reproduction rate in a
community
that's above a certain level everywhere
trump doesn't know what the reproduction
rate is
more social distancing do not open bars
and do not open gymnasiums do not open
until you get this under control
under more control but when you do open
give the people the capacity to be able
to open and have the capacity
to do it safely for example schools
schools they need a lot of money to
open they need to deal with ventilation
systems they need to deal with smaller
classes
more teachers more pods and he's refused
to support that money or at least up to
now
let's talk about schools president trump
i think we have to respond if i might
please and then i have a phone thank you
and i appreciate that look all he does
is talk about shutdowns but forget about
his democrat governors cuomo in new york
you look at what's going on in
california you look at pennsylvania
north carolina
democrats democrats all they're shut
down so tight
and they're dying they're done nothing's
shut down he supports all these people
all he talks about is shutdowns no we're
not going to shut down
and we have to open our schools and it's
like as an example
i have a young son he also tested
positive
by the time i spoke to the doctor the
second time he was fine it just went
away
young people i guess it's their immune
system let me follow up with you
president trump you've demanded schools
open in person and insist they can do it
safely but just yesterday
boston became the latest city to move
its public school system entirely online
that's right coronavirus spike what is
your message to parents who worry
that sending their children to school
will endanger not only their kids but
also their teachers and families i want
to open the schools
the transmittal rate to the teachers is
very small but i want to open the
schools we have to open our country
we're not going to have a country
you can't do this we can't keep this
country close this is a
massive country with a massive economy
huge country losing their jobs they're
committing suicide
there's depression alcohol drugs at a
level that nobody's ever seen before
there's abuse
tremendous abuse we have to open our
country
abuse i've said it often the cure cannot
be worse
than the problem itself and that's
what's happening and he wants to close
down he'll close down the country
if one person in our in our massive
bureaucracy says we should close it down
vice president biden
simply not true we ought to be able to
walk and chew gum at the same time
we ought to be able to safely open but
when they need resources to open
you need to be able to for example if
you're going to open a business
have social distancing within the
business you need to have if you have a
restaurant you need to have
plexiglas dividers so people cannot
infect one another
you need to be in a position where you
can take testing
rapidly and know whether a person is in
fact infected
you need to be able to trace you need to
be able to provide all the
resources that are needed to do this and
that is not inconsistent with
saying that what we're going to make
sure that we open safely and by the way
all you teachers out there not that many
of you are going to die so don't worry
about it
so don't worry about it come on
president trump let me follow up with
you quickly by the way i will say this
if you go and look at what's happened to
new york
it's a ghost town it's a ghost town and
when you talk about plexiglass these are
restaurants that are dying
these are businesses with no money
putting a plexiglass is unbelievably
expensive
and it's not the answer i mean you're
going to sit there in a cubicle
wrapped around with plastic these are
businesses that are dying joe you can't
do that to people
you just can't take a look at new york
and what's happened to my wonderful city
for
for so many years i loved it it was
vibrant it's dying everyone's leaving
new york
take a look new york has done in terms
of turning the curve down in terms of
the number of people dying
and i don't look at this in terms of the
way he does blue states and red states
they're all the united states
and look at the states that are having
such trump's getting crushed guys the
coronavirus
they're the red states they're the
states in the midwest of the states in
the upper midwest that's where the spike
is occurring significantly
but they're all americans they're all
americans and what we have to do is say
wear these masks number one make sure we
get the help that the businesses need
that has
monies already been passed to do that
it's been out there since
the beginning of the summer and
nothing's happened
president new york has requested more
than 40
000 people 11 000 people in nursing
president trump say spike take a look at
what's happening
in pennsylvania where they've had it
closed take a look at what's happening
with your friend
in michigan where her husband's the only
one allowed to do anything
it's been like a prison now it was just
ruled unconstitutional
take a look at north carolina they're
having spikes and they've been closed
and they're getting a look on joe's face
we can't let that happen joe
you can't let that happen we have to
open up joe's not letting everything is
happening under trump's watch
protect our seniors we have to protect
our elderly we have to protect
especially our seniors with heart
problems and diabetes problems
and we will protect we have the best
testing in the world by far
that's why we have so many cases let me
follow up with you before we move on to
our next section president trump this
week you called dr anthony fauci the
nation's best known infectious disease
expert quote a disaster disaster
you described him and other medical
experts as quote idiots
if you're not listening to them who are
you listening to i'm listening to all of
them including anthony i get along very
well with anthony but
he did say don't wear masks he's seven
months ago dude
you know this is not what did he say
seven months ago
i think he's a democrat but that's okay
he said this is not going to be a
problem
we are not going to have a problem at
all when joe says that
i said anthony fauci said and others and
many others and i'm not
knocking him a lot nobody knew look what
nobody knew what this thing was nobody
knew where it was coming from
what it was we've learned a lot but
anthony said don't wear masks now he
wants to wear masks
anthony we've learned a lot if you look
back exact words here's his exact words
this is no problem this is going to go
away soon so he's allowed to make
mistakes he happens to be a good person
vice president biden your response
quickly and then we're going to move on
to the next section our response is that
think about what the president knew in
january and didn't tell the american
people
he was told this was a serious virus
that spread in the air
and it was much worse than much worse
than the flu
he went on record and said to one of
your colleagues
recorded that in fact he knew how
dangerous it was but he didn't want to
tell us
he didn't want to tell us because he
didn't want us to panic he didn't want
us americans don't panic
he panicked but guess what in the
meantime we find out in the new york
times the other day that in fact
his folks went to wall street and said
this is a really dangerous thing
and a memo out of that meeting not from
his administration
but from some of the brokers said sell
short because we've got to get moving
wow dangerous well this is devastating
30 seconds to respond and then
the wall street i don't know somebody
went to wall street you're the one that
takes all the money from wall street i
don't take it
you have raised a lot of money
tremendous amounts of money
and every time you raise money deals are
made you know i could raise so much more
money
as president and as somebody that knows
most of those people
self-destructed wall street the heads of
every company in america
i would blow away every record but i
don't want to do that
biden's right to just laugh and then you
bring up wall street you shouldn't be
bringing up wall street
because you're the one that takes the
money from wall street not me
i could blow away your records that like
you wouldn't believe we don't need money
we have plenty of money in fact
we beat hillary clinton with a tiny
fraction of the money that she was able
to all right gentlemen
don't tell me about this average
contribution 43 all right we're going to
move on to our next section
which is national security and i do want
to start oh my god
of our elections and some breaking news
from overnight just last night
top intelligence officials confirmed
again that both russia and iran
are working to influence this election
both countries have obtained
u.s voter registration information these
officials say
and iran sent intimidating messages to
florida
voters this question goes to you mr vice
president what would you do
to put an end to this threat you have
two minutes uninterrupted
i made it clear and i asked everyone
else to take the pledge
i made it clear that any country no
matter who it is that interferes in
american elections
will pay a price they will pay a price
and it's been overwhelmingly clear this
election i won't even get into the last
one
this election that russia has been
involved china has been involved to some
degree and now we learn that
that that iran is involved they
will pay a price if i'm elected they're
interfering with american
sovereignty that's what's going on right
now they're interfering with american
sovereignty
and to the best of my knowledge i don't
think the president said anything to
putin about it
i don't think he's stalking them a lot i
don't think he said a word i don't know
why
he hadn't said a word to putin about it
and i don't know what he has recently
said if anything
to the iranians my guess is he'd
probably be more outspoken
with regard to the iranians but the
point is this folks
we are in a situation where we have
foreign company
countries trying to interfere in the
outcome of our election his old
own national security advisor told him
that what is happening with his
buddy well i don't guys shouldn't well i
will his buddy
rudy giuliani he's being used as a
russian pawn
he's being fed information that is
russian
that is not true and then what happens
nothing happens
and then you find out that everything is
going on here
about russia is wanting to make sure
that i do not get elected the next
president united states
because they know i know them and they
know
me i don't understand why this president
is unwilling to take on putin
when he's actually paying bounties to
kill american soldiers in afghanistan
when he's engaged in activities that are
trying to destabilize all of
nato i don't know why he doesn't do it
but it's worth
asking the question why isn't that being
done
any country that interferes with us will
in fact pay a price because they're
affecting our sovereignty
president trump same question to you let
me let me ask the question you're gonna
have two minutes to respond for two
elections in a row now there has been
substantial interference from foreign
adversaries
what would you do in your next term to
put an end to this two minutes
let me respond to the first part as joe
answered joe got three and a half
million dollars from russia
and it came through putin because he was
very friendly with the
former mayor of moscow and it was the
mayor of moscow's wife and
you got three and a half million dollars
your family got three and a half million
dollars and
you know someday you're gonna have to
explain why did you get three and a half
i never got i don't think this is
working for trump money from russia
now about your thing last night i knew
all about that
and through john who was john ratcliffe
who was fantastic dni
he said the one thing that's common to
both of them
they both want you to lose because there
has been nobody tougher to russia
with between the sanctions john told
trump about biden's thing
between the sanctions between all of
what i've done with nato you know i've
got the nato countries to put up
an extra 130 billion going to 420
billion dollars a year
that's to guard against russia i sold
while he was selling pillows and sheets
i sold tank busters to ukraine there has
been nobody
tougher this is crazy on russia than
donald trump
and i'll tell you they were so bad they
took i thread count cotton the submarine
port you remember that very well
during your term during you and barack
obama
they took over a big part of what should
have been ukraine you handed it to him
but you were getting a lot of money from
russia they were paying you a lot of
money
and they probably still are but now with
what came out today
it's even worse wow all of the emails
the emails the horrible emails of the
kind of money that you were raking in
you and your family
and joe you were vice president when
some of this was happening
and it should have never happened and i
think you owe an explanation to the
american people
why is it somebody just had a news
conference a little while
what's the allegation actually supposed
to work with you and your family
but what he said was damning and
regardless of me i think you have to
clean it up and talk to the american
people maybe you can do it right now
vice president he's muted oh my god and
then i do want to follow up on the
election security i have not
taken a penny from any foreign source
ever
in my life we learned that this
president paid
50 times the tax in china has a secret
bank account
with china does business in china
and in fact is on fire
i've not taken a single penny from any
country
whatsoever ever number one number two
this is a president i have released all
of my tax returns
22 years go look at them 22 years of my
tax return
you have not released a single solitary
year of your
tax return he's under our debt why are
you unwilling
the foreign countries are paying you a
lot russia's paying you a lot
china's painting a lot and your hotels
and all your businesses all around the
country
all around the world and china's
building a new road to a new
a golf course you have overseas so
what's going on here why don't release
your tax return or stop talking about
corruption
president trump your response first of
all i called my accountants
underwrote it i'm going to release them
and certainly i want to do it
and it'll show how successful how great
this company is but
much more importantly than that people
were saying 750
i asked them a week ago statutory what
did they pay
they said sir you prepaid tens of
millions of dollars i prepaid my tax
tens over the best number of years tens
of millions of dollars i prepaid
because at some point they think it's an
estimate they think i may have to pay
tax
so i already prepaid it nobody told me
god did your account nobody told you
that
excuse me and it wasn't written whenever
they write this they keep talking about
750
which i think is a filing fee but let me
just tell you i prepaid
millions and millions of dollars in
taxes
number one number two i don't make money
from china you do
i don't make money from ukraine you do i
don't make money from
russia you made three and a half million
dollars joe
and your son gave you they even have a
statement that
we have to give ten percent to the big
man you're the big man i think
i don't know maybe you're not but you're
the big man i think
you're the big man present to the big
man joe what's that all about
it's terrible all right gentlemen i want
to ask you both some questions about all
of this but
i'm going to let you both respond very
quickly you just said you spoke to your
accountant about potentially releasing
your taxes did he tell you when you can
release them do you
have what is the deadline for when
you're going to release it i get treated
worse than the tea party got treated
because i have a lot of people in there
deep down in the irs they treat me
horribly we made a deal it was all
settled until i decided to run for
president
i get treated very badly by the irs very
whining
but we had a deal all done as soon as
we're completed with the deal i want to
release it
but he's making deals with the irs now
millions of dollars
and it's worse than paying i paid in
advance it's called pre-paying your
taxes i paid in it i want to ask you
both
about questions regarding your potential
foreign entanglements and questions that
have been raised to give you both a
chance
to talk about this more broadly respond
very quickly and then i'll get to my
question
why did he's been saying this for four
years
show us just show us stop playing around
you've been saying for four years you're
gonna release your taxes nobody knows it
mr president oh my god
is you're not paying your taxes or
you're paying taxes that are so low
when last time he said what he paid he
said i only pay that little because i'm
smart
i know how to game the system come on
come on man president trump and then i
want to get to two questions to both of
you
i was put through a phony witch hunt
for three years it started
before i even got elected they spied on
my campaign
no president should ever have to go
through what i went through here we go
say this mueller and 18 angry democrats
and fbi agents all over the place spent
48 million dollars
they went through everything i had
including my tax returns
and they found absolutely no collusion
and nothing wrong
48 million i guarantee you if i spent 1
million on youtube i could find plenty
wrong
because the kind of things that you've
done and the kind of monies that your
family has taken
i mean your brother made money in iraq
millions of dollars
your other brother made a fortune and
it's all through you joe and they say
you get some of it
and you do live they say they have
houses all over the place you live very
well
all right gentlemen let me just ask some
questions about all of this biden
laughing is the perfect response i think
your son has done in china
and for a ukrainian energy company when
you were vice president
in retrospect was anything let's hear
about it relationships inappropriate or
unethical
nothing was unethical here's what the
deal
with regard to ukraine we had this whole
question about whether or not
because he was on the board i later
learned of a barisma
a company that somehow i had done
something wrong
yet every single solitary person when he
was going through his impeachment
testifying under oath who worked for him
said i did my
job impeccably i carried out u.s policy
not one single solitary thing was out of
line
not a single thing number one number two
the guy who got in trouble in ukraine
was this guy trying to bribe
the ukrainian government to say
something negative about me
which i would not do true because it
never
ever ever happened my son has not made
money in terms of this thing about uh
what are you talking about
china i have not had the only guy made
money from china is this guy
he's the only one nobody else has made
money from china
never going to do it let me ask my
question to you
could i just one one thing very quickly
didn't have a job for a long time
was sadly no longer in the military
service i won't get into that
and he didn't have a job as soon as he
became vice president
barisma not the best look not the best
reputation in the world
i hear they paid him 183 000
a month listen to this 183
and they gave him a three million dollar
upfront payment all right and he had no
energy i'm going to let the vice
president respond to that quickly and
then i need to get to a question to you
very no basis for that
everybody investigated that no one said
anything he did was wrong in ukraine
okay president trump this is for you
since you took office you've never
divested from your business you've
personally promoted your properties
abroad
a report this week which was referenced
does indicate that your company has a
bank account in china
so how can voters know that you don't
have any foreign conflicts of interest
i have many bank accounts and they're
all listed and they're all over the
place i mean
i was a businessman doing business the
bank account you're referring to
which is everybody knows about it it's
listed the bank account was in
2013. that's what it was it was opened
in two
it was closed in 2015 i believe
and then i decided because i was going
to do i was thinking about doing a deal
in china like
millions of other people millions of
people are doing deals in china i'm not
going to do it
didn't like it i decided not to do it
had an account open
and i closed it okay excuse me and then
unlike him where he's vice president and
he does business
i then decided to run for president
after that that was before
so i closed it before i even ran for
president
he closed it before he even opened it
big difference
he is the vice president of the united
states and his son
his brother and his other brother are
getting rich
they're like a vacuum cleaner they're
sucking money
thank you i do want to ask you
vice president biden about china let's
talk about china more broadly
there have of course president trump has
said that they should pay
for not being fully transparent in
regards to the coronavirus
if you were president would you make
china pay and please be specific what
would that look like
pay what right it was played by the
international rules
not like he has done he has caused the
deficit of china to go up
not down with china up not
down we are making sure that in order to
do business in china you have to give
all your intellectual property you have
to get a have a partner in china is 51
we would not do that at all number one
number two we're in a situation where
china would have to play by the rules
internationally as well
when i met with xi that and uh when i
was still vice president he said we're
setting up air identification zones in
the
in the south china sea you can't fly
through them i said we're gonna fly
through them we just flew b-52 b-1
bombers
through it we're not going to pay
attention they have to play by the rules
and what's he do he embraces guys like
the thugs like in north korea and
and and the chinese president and putin
and others
and he pokes his finger in the eye of
all of our friends all of our allies
we make up only we're we're 25
25 of the world's economy we need to be
having the rest of our friends
with us saying to china these are the
rules you play by them or you're going
to pay the price for not paying by them
economically that's the way i will run
it and that's what we did and upholding
steel tariffs and a range of other
things and we were president vice
president all right
let's talk about north korea let's just
mean i have to respond to that
okay very quickly and then we're going
to invite you with a few and a half
dollars from chinatown
after spending 10 minutes in office and
being in now his son's a billionaire
number one
number two there's a very strong email
talking about strong wanting to make 10
million dollars a year
for introductions president trump on
china policy though what's new
are you gonna do what specifically are
you going to do to
no answer you're not getting an answer
china is paying they're paying billions
and billions of dollars i just gave 28
billion
i just gave 28 billion dollars to our
farmers taxpayers
that's what taxpayers money didn't come
oh yeah yeah you know the taxpayer is
it's called china
china he still doesn't know how terrific
they were to pay it joe
they devalued their currency and they
also paid out he doesn't know how
terrific
our farmers are great farmers because
they were targeted you never
charged them anything also i charged
25 on dumped steel because they were
killing our stealing
we were not going to have a steel index
okay and now we have a stealer okay
vice president biden your response
please our response is look this isn't
about
there's a reason why he's bringing up
all this malarkey
there's a reason for it he doesn't want
to talk about the these
the substantive issues it's not about
his family and my family
it's about your family and your family's
hurting badly
if you're making less than if you're a
middle-class family
you're getting hurt badly right now
you're sitting at the kitchen table this
morning deciding
well we can't get new tires they're bald
because we have to wait another month or
so
or are we going to be able to pay the
mortgage or who's going to tell her she
can't go back to
to community college they're the
decisions you're making
in the middle class families like i grew
up in scranton and clemont
they're in trouble we should be talking
about your families but that's the last
thing he wants to talk
about i wanted to say i want to talk
about north korea
ten seconds mr president ten seconds
political statement
let's get off this china thing and then
he looks the family around the table
everything
just a typical politician let's talk
about a typical politician okay
that's why i got elected let's get off
the subject of china let's talk around
sitting around the table
come on joe you can do better we're
going to talk about north korea now
president trump you've met with north
korean leader kim jong-un
a sinking man looking for a lifesaver
beautiful letters with him you've touted
the fact that there hasn't been a war
or a long-range missile test and yet
north korea recently rolled out its
biggest ever intercontinental ballistic
missile
and continues to develop its nuclear
arsenal do you see that as a betrayal of
the relationship you forged just 30
seconds here because we need to get on
to the next so
when i met with barack obama we sat in
the white house
right at the beginning had a great
conversation was supposed to be 15
minutes and it was well over an hour
we had milkshakes the biggest problem we
have with north is north korea
he indicated we will be in a war with
north korea guess what
it would be a nuclear war and he does
have plenty of nuclear capability
in the meantime i have a very good
relationship with him different kind of
a guy but he probably thinks the same
thing about me
we have a different kind of a
relationship we have a very good
relationship
and there's no war and you know about
two months ago
he broke into a certain area they said
oh there's going to be trouble he said
no they're not
because he's not going to do that and i
was right well instead of being in a war
where millions of people sold you know
is 25 miles away
millions and millions 32 million people
in seoul millions of people would be
dead right now president trump that's 30
seconds
vice president biden to you north korea
conducted four nuclear tests
the obama administration why do you
think you would be able to reign
in this persistent threat because i'd
make it clear which we were making clear
to china they had to be part of the deal
because here's the re
i made it clear and as a spokesperson in
the administration when i went to china
that they said why are you moving your
missile defense up so close
why are you moving more forces here why
you continue to do
military maneuvers with south korea i
said because
north korea is a problem and we're going
to continue to do it so we can control
them
we're going to make sure we can control
them and make sure they cannot hurt us
and so if you want to do something about
it step up and help if not
it's going to continue what has he done
he's legitimized north korea
he's talked about his good buddy who's a
thug beautiful letter
and he talks about how we're better off
and they are have much more capable
missiles
able to reach u.s territory much more
easily than ever did before let me
follow up with you
vice president biden you've said you
wouldn't meet with kim jong-un without
preconditions are there any conditions
under which you would meet with him
on the condition that he would agree
that he would be drawing down his
nuclear capacity to get that the korean
peninsula should be nuclear free zone
all right let's move on to america
very quickly 10 seconds if they tried to
meet with him he wouldn't do it
he didn't like obama he didn't like him
this is a lie okay i gotta give him a
chance this is a lie
do it and it's okay you know what north
korea
we're not in a war we have a good
relationship you know people don't
understand having a good relationship
with leaders of other countries
he's belligerent man we had a good
relationship with
hitler before he in fact invaded europe
the rest of europe come come on ma'am
meet with president obama's because
president obama said we're going to talk
about denuclearization
we're not going to legitimize you we're
going to continue to put stronger and
stronger
sanctions on you that's why he wouldn't
meet with us
all right and it didn't work excuse me
what didn't happen
chris president trump okay they left me
a mess
north korea was a mess and in fact if
you remember the first two or three
months questions tonight
it was a very dangerous period in my
first three months before we
sort of worked things out a little super
dangerous they
left us a mess and obama would be i
think
the first to say it was the single
biggest problem he thought
that our country okay let's move on to
american families and the economy on
one of the issues that's not a good
topic for trump that is health care as
you both know
today there was a key vote on a new
supreme court justice amy coney barrett
and health care is at the center of her
confirmation fight
over 20 million americans get their
health insurance through the affordable
care act
it's headed to the supreme court and
your administration mr president is
advocating for the court to overturn it
if the supreme court does overturn that
law those
20 million americans could lose their
health insurance almost overnight so
what would you do
if those people have their health
insurance taken away you have two
minutes uninterrupted
first of all i've already done something
that nobody thought was possible
through the legislature i terminated the
individual mandate part of obamacare
as we call it the individual mandate
where you have to pay a fortune for the
privilege of
not having to pay for bad health
insurance i terminated it's gone
now it's in court because obamacare is
no good
but then i made a decision run it as
well as you can to my people
great people run it as well as you can i
could have gone the other route and made
everybody very unhappy
they ran it premiums are down
everything's down here's the problem
no matter how well you run it it's no
good what we'd like to do
is terminate it we have the individual
mandate
done i don't know that it's going to
work if we don't win
we will have to run it and we'll have
obamacare but it'll be better run
so what's the plan is obamacare does
anybody understand individual mandate
it's much different pre-existing
conditions will always stay
what i would like to do is a much better
health care much better
will always protect people with
pre-existing so i'd like to terminate
obamacare come up with a brand new
beautiful health care
the democrats will do it because
there'll be tremendous pressure on them
and we might even have the house by that
time
and i think we're going to win the house
okay and you'll see but i think we're
going to win the house
but there's no chance that healthcare
always protecting people
with pre-existing conditions and one
thing very important we have 180 million
people out there
that have great private health care for
private health talking about with
obamacare
great job is going to terminate all of
those policies
these are people that love their health
care people that have been successful
almost no one loves their health care
been successful
they have 180 million plants 180 million
people
families under what he wants to do which
will
basically be socialized medicine he
won't even have a choice i wish they
want to terminate 180 million plans
not true though an incredible job on
healthcare
and we're going to do even better okay
muted muted brutal mute oh my god
on obamacare mute hammer what is your
plan if the law is ruled
unconstitutional by the supreme
court you have two minutes uninterrupted
what i'm going to do
is pass obamacare with a public option
will become biden care the public option
is an option that says that
if you in fact do jealous trump if you
qualify for medicaid and you do not have
the wherewithal
then your state to get medicaid you
automatically are enrolled
providing competition for insurance
companies that's what's going to happen
secondly
we're going to make sure we reduce the
premiums and reduce drug prices
by making sure that there's competition
that doesn't exist now by allowing
the medicare to negotiate drug prices
with the insurance companies thirdly
the idea that i want to eliminate
private insurance the reason why i had
such a fight
for with 20 candidates for the
nomination was
i support private insurance that's why
i did not one single person with private
insurance
would lose their insurance under my plan
nor
did they under obamacare they did not
lose their insurance
unless they chose they wanted to go to
something else lastly
we're going to make sure we're in a
situation that we actually
protect pre-existing there's no way he
can protect pre-existing conditions
none zero you can't do it in the ether
he's been talking about this for a long
time there is no he's never come up with
a plan i guess we're going to get
the pre-existing condition planned the
same time we get the infrastructure plan
that we've been waiting since 1718. i'm
going to steal the super chat this is
very good
for a few more minutes i know you're
getting anxious the uh
the fact is that the has already cost
the american people
because of his terrible handling of the
covet virus and economic spillover
10 million people have lost their
private insurance
and he wants to take away 22 million
more people who have it under obamacare
and over 110 million people with
pre-existing conditions
and all the people from covert are going
to have pre-existing conditions
what are they going to do i have a
follow-up for you vice president biden
it relates to something that president
trump said he's accusing you of wanting
socialized medicine what do you say to
people
who have concerns that your health care
plan which includes a government
insurance option takes the country
one step closer to a health care system
run entirely by the government
we wish right it's ridiculous it's like
saying that you know
we're uh the idea that the fact that
there's a public option that people can
choose
that makes it a socialist plan look the
difference between the president i think
health care is not
a privilege it's a right everyone should
have the right to have affordable health
care
and i am very proud of my plan it's
gotten endorsed by
all the major labor unions as well as as
well as a whole range of other people
who in fact are concerned in the medical
field
this is something that's going to save
people's lives and this is going to give
some
people an opportunity an opportunity to
have health care for their children
how many of you home are worried and
rolling around in bed tonight wondering
what in god's name you're going to do if
you get sick because you've lost your
home insurance your your health
insurance your company's gone under
we have to provide health insurance for
people at an affordable rate and that's
what i do
president trump he was here for 47 years
he didn't do it he was now there as vice
president for eight years and it's not
like it was 25 years ago
it was three and three quarters it was
just a little while ago right less than
four years ago
he didn't do anything he didn't do it he
wants socialized medicine and it's not
that he wants it his vice president
i mean she is is more liberal
than bernie sanders and wants it even
more bernie sanders once said
the democrats won you're going to have
socialized medicine just like you want
to with fracking
we're not going to have fracking we're
going to stop fracking we're going to
stop fracking then he goes to
pennsylvania after he gets a nomination
where he got very lucky to get it
and he goes to pennsylvania and he says
oh we're going to have fracking
and you never ask that question and by
the way so far i respect very much the
way you're handling this i have to
by the way but somebody should ask the
question trump couldn't help himself he
had to attack the moderator
he had to attack her we have a number of
topics
we're going to get to we're going to get
to the same thing with socializing
vice president your response please my
response is people deserve to have
affordable health care
period period period period and the
biden care proposal will in fact
provide for that affordable health care
lower premiums what we're going to do is
going to cost some money
it's going to cost over 750 billion
dollars over 10 years to do it
and they're going to have lower premiums
you can buy into the better plans
the cheaper plans lower your premiums
deal with
unders unexpected billing and have your
drug prices drop significantly he keeps
talking about it he hasn't done
a thing he's had four years he's done
nothing not a thing just it went here
and i want to talk about what he says
public action he's talking about
socialized medicine
and when he and and healthcare when he
doesn't get it public option
he's talking about destroying your
medicare totally destroyed
and destroying your social security and
this whole country will come down
you know public options destroy social
security he tried it in a state his
governor was a very liberal governor
they want to make it work okay
let's hear your question vice president
it doesn't matter
very confused guy he thinks he's running
against somebody else yeah he's running
against
joe biden right i beat all those other
people because i disagreed with them
this is brutal guys that we're in a
situation that are going to destroy
medicare
this is the guy that the actuary
medicare said
if in fact at social security if in fact
he continues to
withhold his plan to withhold the tax on
social security
social security will be bankrupt in by
2023
with no way to make up for it it's
unclear actually trying to cut
medicare so i don't i mean the idea that
donald trump
is lecturing me on social security and
medicare
come on come on man he tried to get rid
of it he tried to hurt social security
years ago
years ago in 1993 he said we could
negotiate social security years ago
all right let's move on what a lie i
have to move on to the next
27 years ago we're not going to have
time to talk about it if i'm elected
if he's elected the stock market will
crash okay
very quickly the idea that the stock
market is booming is his only measure of
what's happening
where i come from in scranton and claim
on that people don't live off of the
stock market
beautiful just in the last three
three years during this crisis said the
the billionaires in this country made
according to
the wall street 700 billion more
dollars and by the way stocks do better
under democratic press because by the
way that's his only measure
what happens to the ordinary people out
there what happens to them
let's talk 401k 401ks are through the
roof we're going to move on
through the roof and he doesn't come
from scranton that's
like one of he lived there for a short
period of time before he even knew
we're going to move on and he left and
the people of pennsylvania let me move
on to my next question
oh he left stranton well then vote for
trump right people are out of work
and as of tonight 8 million more
americans have fallen into poverty
and more families are going hungry every
day those hit hardest are women
and people of color they see washington
fighting over a relief bill
mr president why haven't you been able
to get them the help they need
30 seconds here nancy pelosi doesn't
want to approve it i do
but you're the president i do but i
still have to get unfortunately that's
one of the reasons i think we're going
to take over the house because of her
nancy pelosi doesn't want to approve
anything because she'd love to have some
victories
on a date called november 3rd nancy
pelosi does not want to approve it
we are ready willing and able to do
something don't forget we've
already approved three plans that's gone
through including the democrats in all
fairness
three plans it's near the election
because she thinks it helps her
politically i think it hurts her
politically all right mr vice president
no the republican leader in in the
united states senate said he can't pass
it
he will not be able to pass it he does
not have republican votes
why isn't he talking to his republican
friends let me follow up with you vice
president
wow let me let me ask vice president
biden a question you are the leader of
the democratic party
why have you not pushed the democrats to
get a deal for the american people well
i have and they have pushed it look they
passed this act
all the way back in the beginning of the
summer he's a candidate guys i mean you
know
it's been out there this heroes act has
been sitting there
and look it's what's happening when i
was in charge of the recovery act with
800 billion dollars
i was able to get 145 billion dollars to
local communities
that have to balance their budgets in
states that have to balance the budget
so then
have to fire fire to have to fire
firefighters
teachers first responders law
enforcement officers so they could keep
their cities and counties running
he will not support that they have not
done a thing for them
and mitch mcconnell said let him go
bankrupt let him go bankrupt
come on what's the matter bill that was
passed in the house was a bailout
of badly run high crime democrat
all run by democrats cities and states
wow
it's a way of getting a lot of money
billions that's a way to win swing
states huh
it was also a way of getting a lot of
money from our people's pockets to
people that come into our country
illegally we were going to take care of
everything for them and what that does
and i'd love to do that i'd love to help
them but what that does
everybody all over the world will start
pouring into our country we can't do it
this was a way of taking care of them
this was a way of spending on things
that had nothing to do with covet as per
your question
but it was really a big bailout for
badly run
democrat cities and states all right if
i get elected
i'm not going to i'm running as a proud
democrat but i'm going to be an american
president
how do you see red states and blue
states obvious responses as american
united states
democrats every single state out there
finds themselves in trouble
they're going to start laying off
whether they're red or blue
cops firefighters first responders
because
teachers because they have to balance
their budget and the founders were smart
they allowed the federal government to
deficit spend to compensate
for the united states of america trump's
dead in the water talk about the minimum
wage gentlemen mr vice president
we are talking a lot about struggling
small businesses yes and business owners
these days
do you think this is the right time to
ask them to raise the minimum wage you
of course support a 15
federal minimum i do because i think one
of the things we're going to have to do
is we're going to have to bail them out
too
we should be bailing them out now those
small businesses
you got one in six of them going under
they're not going to be able to make it
back
they passed the pro a package that
allows us
to be able to call ppp money's supposed
to go to help them do everything from
organize how they can deal with their
business as being open safely
schools how they can make classrooms
smaller how they can hire more teachers
how they can put ventilation systems in
they need the help the businesses as
well as the schools
need the help but this these guys will
not help them
it's not giving them any of the money we
are going to move on to immigration
but i want to say we have to help our
small businesses by raising the minimum
wage that's not helping
i i think it should be a state option
alabama
is different than new york new york is
different from vermont every state is
different
it should be a state app you said we
have to help it's very important
we have to help our small businesses how
are you helping your small businesses
when you're forcing wages
what's going to happen and what's been
proven to happen is when you do that
these small businesses
fire many of their employees you said
recently you would consider
raising the federal minimum wage to 15
an hour you said recently you would
consider raising the federal minimum
wage to 50
an hour that's still the case and i
would consider it yeah but he's got to
attack it if i don't
illustration in a second administration
but not to a level second term
all these businesses out of business it
should be a state option
look everything in different places i
know different places they're all
different
some places fifteen dollars is not so
bad
in other places other states fifteen
dollars okay president trump thank you
quick response that is true i'm in favor
of a regionalized minimum wage
maybe low poverty people are making six
seven eight bucks an hour these first
responders we all clap for
as they come down the street because
they've allowed us to make it
what's happening they deserve a minimum
wage of 15
anything below that puts you below the
poverty level and there is no evidence
that when you raise the minimum wage
businesses go out of business that is
simply not true
we're going to talk about immigration
we're going to talk about immigration
now gentlemen
and we're going to talk about families
within this context mr president your
administration is doing
legal at the border at least 4 000 kids
you've since reversed your zero
tolerance policy
but the united states can't locate the
parents of more than 500 children
so how will these families ever be
reunited children
are brought here by coyotes and lots of
bad people
cartels and they're brought here and
they used to use them to get into our
country
we now have as strong a border as we've
ever had
we're over 400 miles of brand new wall
you see the numbers and we let people in
but they have to come in legally and
they come in through but how will you
reunite
the questions with their family they
built cages you know they used to say
i built the cages and then they had a
picture in a certain
newspaper there was a picture of these
horrible cages
and they said look at these cages
president trump built them
and then it was determined they were
built in 2014.
that was him reunite the kids yes we're
working on it very we're we're trying
we're looking at it very strongly these
kids come out without the parents they
come over through cartels and through
coyotes and through gangs
vice president let me bring you into
this conversation quick response and
then another question to you these 500
plus kids
came with parents they separated them at
the border
to make it a disincentive to come to
begin with
they real tough we're really strong and
guess what
they cannot it's not coyotes didn't
bring them over their
parents were with them they got
separated from their parents
and it makes us a laughing stock and
violates every notion of who we are
as a nation oh my god let me ask you a
photo they
let's talk about what we're talking
about what happened
parents were ripped their kids were
ripped from their arms
and separated and now they cannot find
over 500 of
sets of those parents and those kids are
alone
nowhere to go nowhere to go it's
criminal
it's criminal let me ask kristin i will
say this they went down
we brought reporters everything they are
so
well taken care of oh my god that was so
clean
some of them haven't been reunited but
just ask they're alone but they have
of these i'd love you to ask him that
who built the cages
let me ask about your immigration policy
mr vice president the obama
administration did fail to deliver
immigration reform which had been a key
promise during the administration it
also presided over record deportations
as well as
family detentions at the border before
changing course so why should voters
trust you with an immigration overhaul
now
because we made a mistake it made two it
took too long to get it right
it took too long to get it right i'll be
president of the united states not vice
president united states
and the fact is i've made it very clear
within
100 days i'm going to send to the united
states congress a pathway to citizenship
for
over 11 million undocumented people and
all of those
so-called dreamers those daca kids
they're going to be immediately
certified again to be able to stay
in this country and put on a path to
citizenship the idea that
they are being sent home by this guy and
they want to do that
is they've gone to a country they've
never seen before i can imagine you're
five years old your parents are taking
it across
the rio grande river and is
and it's illegal and you say oh no mom
leave me here i'm not going to go with
you
they've been here many of them are model
citizens over twenty thousand are first
responders
out there taking care of people during
this crisis we
owe them we owe them
president he had eight years to do what
he said he was
going to do and i've changed without
having a
specific we got rid of catch and release
we got rid of a lot of
horrible things that they put in and
that they lived with
but he had eight years he was vice
president he
did nothing except build cages
to keep children in vice president your
response
the catch and release you know what he's
talking about there if in fact you had
a family came across and they were
arrested
they in fact were given a date to show
up for their hearing
they were released and guess what they
showed up for a hearing
this is the first president in history
united states america that's anybody
seeking asylum has to do it in another
country
that's never happened before that's true
agree disagree but that's true you come
to the united states and you make your
case
that i seek asylum based on the
following on the following premise
why i deserve it under american law
they're sitting in a squalor on the
other side of the river
president trump you're responsible for
seconds it just shows that he has no
understanding of immigration of the laws
i think it's the opposite this is a
disaster
a murderer would come in a rapist would
come in
a very bad person would come in we would
take their name
we have to release them into our country
and then you say they come back less
than one percent of the people
come back we have to send ice out and
border patrol out to find them
we would say come back in two years
three years
we're going to give you a court case you
need perry mason we're going to give you
a court case
when you say they come back they don't
come back joe they never come back
only the really i hate to say this
but those with the lowest iq oh my god
let's give vice president biden a chance
to look at biden's reaction
oh my god vice president biden your
response know the law what he's telling
you is simply not true
well check it out they don't come back
check it out all right let's move but we
don't have to worry about it
they terminated it so we'd have to once
trump mentioned low iq it's like let's
just go with something else
name they're going to be in lost take
the loss all right let's talk about
our next section which is race in
america
and i want to talk about the way black
and brown americans
experience race in this country part of
that experience
is something called the talk it happens
regardless of class
and income parents who feel they have no
choice
but to prepare their children for the
chance that they could be targeted
including by the police
for no reason other than the color of
their skin
mr vice president in the next two
minutes i want you to speak
directly to these families do you
understand why these parents
fear for their children i do i do
you know my daughter is a social worker
and uh
she's all she's written a lot about this
she's a
graduate degree from the university of
pennsylvania in social work
and you know uh didn't trump go there
reasons why i ended up working
on the east side of wilmington delaware
which is 90 african-american
was to learn more about what was going
on what i didn't i never had to tell my
daughter
if she's pulled over make sure she puts
for a
traffic stop put both hands on top of
the wheel and don't reach for the glove
box because someone may shoot you
but a black parent no matter how wealthy
or how poor they are
has to teach their child when you're
walking down the street
don't have a hoodie on when you go
across the street making sure that you
in fact
if you get pulled over yes yes sir no
sir
hands on top of the wheel because you
are in fact the victim whether you're
a person making 300 child of a 300 000
every year person
or someone who's on on on food stamps
the fact of the matter is there is
institutional racism america
and we have always said we've never
lived up to it that we hold these truths
to be self-evident all men and women are
created equal well guess what
look at trump have never ever lived up
to but we've all
constantly been moving the needle
further and further to inclusion
not exclusion this is the first
president to come along and says that's
the end of that
we're not going to do that anymore we
have to provide for economic opportunity
better education
better health care better access to
schooling
better access to opportunity to borrow
money to start businesses
all the things we can do and i've laid
out a clear plan
as to how to do those things just to
give people a shot
it's about accumulating the ability to
have wealth as well as it is
to be free from violence president trump
same question to you and let me remind
you of the question i would like you to
speak
directly to these families do you
understand why these parents fear for
their children yes i do
and again he's been in government 47
years he knew
the thing except in 1994 lack of them
such harm to the black community and
they were called and he called them
super predators
and he said that he muted super
predators
and they have never lived that down 1994
your crime bill the super predators
nobody has done more for the black
community than donald trump and if you
look
with the exception of maybe lincoln
possible exception but the assumption of
abraham lincoln
nobody has done what i've done criminal
justice reform
obama and joe didn't do it
i don't even think they tried because
they had no chance at doing it
they might have wanted to do it but if
you had to see the arms i had a twist to
get that done
it was not a pretty picture and
everybody knows it including some very
liberal people that
cried in my office they cried in the
oval office two weeks later they're out
saying gee we have to defeat him
criminal justice reform prison reform
it's all about trump do you guys notice
with tim scott a great senator from
south carolina
he came in with this incredible idea for
opportunity zones it's one of the most
successful programs
people don't talk about it tremendous
investment is being made biggest
beneficiary
the black i see how this has nothing to
do with the question and then
historically black
colleges and universities after three
years of coming to the office
i love some of those guys they were
great they came into the office
and they said i said biden visibly
confused why do you keep coming back
because we have no funding i said you
don't have to come back every year we
have to come back
because president obama would never give
them long-term funding
and i did 10 years amazing term funding
and i gave them more money
than they asked for because they said i
think you need more and i said the only
bad part about this is i may never see
you again
they said sir they're friendly with them
and they like me and i like them
but i saved historically colleges and
universes
okay and we're going to talk about both
of your records but your response to
that vice president my response to that
is i
never ever said what he accused me of
saying
the fact of the matter is in 2000 though
after the crime bill had been in
in in in the law for a while this is the
guy who said
the problem with the crime bill there's
not enough people in jail there's not
enough people in jail and go on my
website get the quote the date when he
said it
not enough people he talked about
marauding gangs
young gangs and the people who were
going to maraude our cities
this is a guy who in the central park
five five innocent black kids he
continued to push for making sure
that they got the death penalty none of
them were none of them
were guilty of what the crime of the
crimes they were
suggested look and talk about he granted
he did in fact let 20 people he commuted
20 people sentences
we committed over a thousand people's
sentences over a thousand
the very law he's talking about is the
law that in fact
initiated by barack obama and secondly
we're in a situation we the federal
prison system was reduced by 38
000 people under our administration and
one of these things we should be doing
there should be
no no minimum mandatories
in the law that's why i'm offering 20
billion dollars of states to change
their state laws
to eliminate minimum mandatories and set
up drug courts no one should be going to
jail
because they have a drug problem they
should be going to rehabilitation
not to jail we should fundamentally
change the system and that's what i'm
going to do
but why didn't he do it four years ago
why didn't you do that
four years ago even less than that why
didn't you when you were vice president
you keep talking about all these things
you're going to do and you're going to
do this
just like trump who says he needs a
second term to do anything
you guys did nothing we didn't know joe
i ran because of you
i ran because of barack obama because
you did a poor job
if i thought you did a good job i would
have never run i would have never run
i ran because of you i'm looking at you
now you're a politician
i ran because of you all right vice
president biden your response to that
and then i do have some questions for
both of you
i'll tell you what i uh i hope he does
look at me because what's happening here
is
you know who i am you know who he is
you know his character you know my
character right you know our reputations
for honor and telling the truth
i am anxious to have this race i am
anxious to see this
take place i am the character of the
country is on the ballot
our character is on the ballot look at
us closely let me ask some folks
please respond we're going to have
toughness this is true about russia
ukraine
china other countries well trump repeats
this i hate to mute
we did hit 56 000 live viewers on
youtube which is a record previous was
55 so i really appreciate that
corrupt politician nobody's president
trump i want to stay on the issue of
race
we're talking about last week from hell
president trump we're talking about race
right now and i do want to stay
with you president trump i have to
respond to that please
look very quick there are 50 former
national intelligence folks
who said that what this he's accusing me
of is a russian
plan they have said that this is has all
the care
four five former heads of the c.i.a both
parties
say what he's saying is a bunch of
garbage nobody believes it except of
his and his good friend rudy gianni you
mean the laptop is now
another russia russia russia hoax that's
exactly what
this is exactly what this is where he's
going the laptop
is russia russia i want to stay on the
issue of race you have to be kidding me
here we go
again we're going to continue on the
issue of race mr president
described the black lives matter
movement as a symbol of hate
you've shared a video of a man chanting
white power to millions of
said that your supporters athletes
exercising their first amendment rights
should be fired
what do you say to americans who say
that kind of language from a president
is contributing to a climate of hate and
racial strife well you have to
understand the first time i ever heard
of black lives matter
they were chanting pigs in a blanket
talking about police
pigs pigs talking about our police pigs
in a blanket
fry them like bacon i said that's a
horrible thing and they were marching
down the street
horrible that was my first uh glimpse of
black lives matter i thought it was a
terrible thing
as far as my relationships with
all people i think i have great
relationships with all people
i am the least racist person in this
room
what do you say to americans in the
whole room guys not just on the stage
i don't know what to say i got criminal
justice reform done and prison reform
he's far less racist than melania
colleges and universities
i don't know what to say they can say
anything i mean
they can say anything it's a very it
makes me sad
because i am i am the least racist
person i can't even see the audience
because it's so dark
but i don't care who's in the audience
i'm the least racist person in this room
got it okay eric trump is more racist
okay very quickly and then i have a
follow-up question for you
abraham lincoln here is one of the most
racist presidents we've had in modern
history
he pours fuel on every single
racist fire every single one he started
off his campaign coming down the
escalator saying he's gonna get rid of
those
mexican rapists he's banned muslims
because they're muslims
he has moved around and made everything
worse
across the board he says to them about
the poor boys
last time we were on proud boys tell
them to stand down
and stand ready come on this guy is a
dog whistle about as big as a foghorn
i'm gonna give you ten seconds to
respond and then i have a follow-up he
made a reference to abraham lincoln
where did that come in
i mean you said abraham lincoln no where
did that no
no you said i said he said he's better
abraham lincoln
has anybody done what i've done for the
black community and i'm saying i didn't
say i'm abraham lincoln i said
not since abraham lincoln has anybody
done
what i've done for the black community
now you have done nothing
other than the crime bill which put oh
god
that thousands of black this is
too much mostly in jail all right let me
you know what yeah let me
remember you look at what's happening
with the voting right now
let me ask you remember
let me give you a chance to respond
within this context crime bills that you
supported in the 80s and 90s
contributed to the incarceration of tens
of thousands of young black men
who had small amounts of drugs in their
possession they are sons they are
brothers their fathers their uncles
whose families are still to this day
some of them suffering the consequences
so speak to those families why should
they vote for you one of the things
is that in the 80s we passed 100 percent
all 100 senators voted for it a bill on
drugs and how to deal with drugs it was
a mistake
i've been trying to change the since
then particularly the portion on cocaine
that's why i've been arguing that in
fact we should not
send anyone to jail for a
pure drug offense they should be going
into treatment
across the board that's what we should
be spending money that's why i set up
drug courts which were never funded
by republican friends they should not be
going to jail
for a drug or an alcohol problem they
should be going into
treatment treatment that's what we've
been trying to do
that's what i'm going to get done
because i think the american people have
now seen that in fact it was a mistake
to pass
those laws relating to the drug but they
were not in the crime bill
but why didn't he get it done see it's
all talk no action with his politicians
why didn't he get politicians that's
what i'm going to do when i become
president
you were vice president along with obama
as your president your leader
for eight years why didn't you get it
done you had eight years to get it done
now you're saying you're gonna get it
done because you're all talk and no
action
we got a lot of it done we released 38
anything we got 38 000 prisoners left
you got nothing done 38 000 prisoners
were released from federal prison
we have there were over a thousand
people who were given clemency
we make fact we're the ones that put in
the legislation
saying we could look at pattern and
practice of police departments and what
they were doing
how they were conducting themselves i
could go on but we began the process
we began the process we lost an election
that's why i'm running
to win back that election and change his
terrible policies
why didn't you do it in the eight years
a short time ago why the same could be
asked of why trump's gotten nothing done
you know his health care bill for
thousands of mostly black young men in
prison
now you're saying you're gonna get
you're gonna undo that why didn't you
get it done you had eight years with
obama
you know why joe because you're all talk
and no action all right vice president
biden and then we're going to move on to
the next section
we had a republican congress
that's the answer okay you got to talk
them into it you know
all right we're going to move on to our
next section like i did with
criminal justice reform i had to talk
democrats into
gentlemen oh my god so we got to get on
to
climate change please you both have very
different checking the time
climate change president trump you say
that environmental regulations have hurt
jobs in the energy sector
vice president biden you have said you
see addressing climate change
as an opportunity to create new jobs for
each of you
how would you both combat climate change
and support job growth at the same time
starting with you president trump you
have two minutes uninterrupted
so uh we have the trillion trees program
we have so many different programs i do
love the environment but what i want is
the cleanest crystal clear water
the cleanest air we have the best lowest
number
in carbon emissions which is a big
standard that i notice obama goes with
all the time
not joe i haven't heard joe use the term
because i'm not sure he knows what it
represents or means but i have heard
obama use it
and we have the best carbon emission
numbers that we've had in 35 years
under this administration we are working
so well with
industry but here's what we can't do
look at china
how filthy it is look at russia
look at india filthy china healthy the
the air is filthy the paris accord i
took us out because
we were going to have to spend trillions
of dollars
and we were treated very unfairly when
they put us in there they did us a great
disservice
they were going to take away our
businesses i will not
sacrifice tens of millions of jobs
thousands and thousands of companies
because of
the paris accord it was so unfair china
doesn't kick in
30. russia goes back to a low standard
incoherently he kicked in right away it
would have been
it would have been it would have
destroyed our businesses so
you ready we have done an incredible job
environmentally
we have the cleanest air the cleanest
and the best carbon emission
standards that we've seen in many many
years
vice president we haven't destroyed our
industries
vice president biden two minutes to you
uninterrupted
climate change and climate warming
global warming is an existential threat
to humanity
we have a moral obligation to deal with
it
and we're told by all the leading
scientists in the world we don't have
much time we're going to pass the point
of no return
within the next eight to ten years
former years of this
man eliminating all the regulations that
were put in by us
to clean up the climate to clean up to
limit
the the limit of emissions will put us
in a position where we're going to be in
real
trouble here's where we have a great
opportunity i was able to get
both all the environmental organizations
as well as labor
the people worried about jobs to support
my
climate plan because what it does it
will create
millions of new good paying jobs we're
going to invest in for example
500 000 50 000 50 000
charging stations on our highways so
that we can own the electric car market
of the future
in the meantime china is doing that
we're going to be in a position where
we're going to see to it
that we're going to take 4 million
existing billions
buildings and 2 million existing homes
and retrofit them so they don't leak as
much energy
saving hundreds of millions of barrels
of oil in the process
and creating significant number of jobs
and by the way
the whole idea of what this is all going
to do it's going to create
millions of jobs and it's going to clean
the environment our health
and our jobs are at stake that's what's
happening
and what right now by the way wall
street firms indicated that
my plan my my plan will in fact create
18.6 million jobs seven million more
than
his this is from wall street and i'll
create
one trillion dollars more in economic
growth than his proposal does
not on climate just on the economy
president trump
they came out and said very strongly
six thousand five hundred dollars will
be taken away from families under his
plan
untrue this plan is an economic disaster
if you look at what he wants to do you
know the
if you look at his plan his
environmental plan you know who
developed it
aoc plus three they know nothing
about the climate i mean she's got a
good line of stuff but she knows nothing
about the client oh my god
they're all hopping through hoops for
aoc plus three aoc is the last person to
attack
a real plan costs a hundred trillion
dollars if we had the best year in the
history of our country
for a hundred years we would not even
come
close to a number like that when he says
buildings they want to take buildings
down because i want to make bigger
windows into smaller windows
as far as they're concerned if you had
no window it would be a lovely thing
this is the craziest plan that do the
toilet ramp
and this wasn't done by smart people
this wasn't done by
anybody frankly i don't even know how it
can be good politically
they want to spend a hundred trillion
dollars that's their real number he's
trying to say it was six
it's a hundred trillion dollars that's
life i want to knock down buildings and
build new buildings with little
tiny small little tiny windows and many
other things okay and many other things
no water pressure
and we're running out of time and we
have a lot more questions
so let's hear from the vice president i
have a number of more questions i
thought there were three more minutes
i don't know where he comes up with
these numbers 100 trillion
dollars did you say queens give me a
break this
plan was this is planned endorsed by
every major
every major environmental group and
every labor group
labor because they know the future lies
the future lies and thus being able to
breathe and they know they're good jobs
and getting us there
and by the way the fastest growing
industry in america
are is is is the electric
the excuse me uh solar energy and wind
he thinks wind causes cancer when it's
the fastest growing
jobs and they pay good prevailing wages
45 to 50 bucks an hour we can
grow and we can be cleaner if we go
the route i'm thinking president trump
please respond
we are energy independent for the first
time
we don't need all of these countries
that we had to fight war over because we
needed their energy
we are energy independent i know more
about wind than you do
it's extremely a lot of hot air coming
out of his mouth all the birds
it's very intermittent it's got a lot of
problems and they happen to make the
windmills in both germany and china
and the fumes coming up if you're a
believer in carbon emission
the fumes coming up to make make these
massive windmills
is more than anything that we're talking
about with natural gas which is very
clean one other thing
find me a solar system i love solar but
solar doesn't quite have it yet
powerful and yet to to really run our
big
beautiful factories that we need to
compete with the world
so far it's all a pipe dream but you
know what we'll do
we're going to have the greatest economy
in the world but if you want to kill the
economy
get rid of your oil industry you want
and and what about fracking all right
now let me know let me let me allow vice
president
to respond never said i oppose frackie
you said it on tape i did show the tape
put it on your website i'll put it on
put it on the website
the fact of the matter is flat lying
would you rule out banning fracking
i do rule out benny fracking because the
answer he should say we should get off
fracking actually we need
other industries to transition to get to
ultimately
a complete zero emissions by 20. there's
a better way to answer that what i will
do with fracking over time
is make sure that we can capture the
emissions
from the fracking capture the emissions
from gas
we can do that and we can do that by
investing money
and doing it real quick what biden
should say is by the time i'm done
the path i'm going to set us on we're
not going to need fracking tracking he
said it
i will show that to you tomorrow i am
against fracking
until he got the nomination went to
pennsylvania then he said but you know
what pennsylvania he'll be against it
very soon because his party
is totally against fracking on federal
land i said no fracking use it or oil
unfortunately let me ask this
final question in this section wow and
then i want to move on to our final
section oh my god people of color are
much more likely to live near oil
refineries and chemical plants
in texas there are families who worry
the plants near them
are making them sick your administration
has rolled back regulations on these
kinds of facilities
why should these families give you
another four years in office
the families that we're talking about
are employed heavily and they are making
a lot of money more money than they've
ever made heavy important look at the
kind of numbers that we produce for
hispanic
or black for asian it's nine times
greater the percentage gain
than it was under in three years that it
was under
eight years of the two of them
to put it nicely what nine times more
now somebody lives i have not heard the
numbers or the state
statistics that you're saying but
they're making a tremendous amount of
money
economically we saved it and i saved it
again a number of months ago when oil
was crashing because of the pandemic
we saved it we got say what you want
about relationship we got saudi arabia
mexico and russia to cut back way back
we saved our oil industry
and now it's very vibrant together and
everybody has very inexpensive gasoline
vice president biden nowhere to go but
we're gonna have a final question for
both of you my response is that those
people live on what they call fence
lines he doesn't understand this
they live near chemical plants that in
fact pollute
chemical plants and oil plants and
refineries to pollute
i used to live near that when i was
growing up in clemont delaware
and all the more oral refineries in
marcus hook and the delaware river than
there is
any place including in houston at the
time when my mom get in the car and when
it when her first frost
to drive me to school turned into the
windshield wiper there'd been oil slick
in the window
that's why so many people in my state
were dying and getting cancer
the fact is those front-line communities
it doesn't matter what you're paying
them it matters
how you keep them safe what do you do
and you impose restrictions on the
pollutions
that the pollutants coming out of those
fence line
communities okay i have one final would
he close down the island
if it falls or would you close down the
earth i would transition from the oil
industry yes
oh transition
i would stop why would you do that
because the oil industry
pollutes isn't it obvious significantly
i said here's the deal but that's a big
statement
well if you let me finish this because
it has to be replaced by renewable
energy over time
over time and i'd stop giving to the oil
industry i'd stop giving them federal
subsidies
he won't give federal subsidies to the
to the gas which excuse me to the
to uh solar and wind yeah why are we
giving it to oil industry
we actually do contribute to solar and
wind that's maybe the biggest statement
in terms of business
that's the biggest thing okay because
basically i love it i love it
destroy the oil industry will you
remember that texas would you
remember that pennsylvania oklahoma
trump's worried about losing texas
and i have to get to the final question
vice president biden
he takes everything out of context but
the point is look
we have to move toward a net zero
emissions
of course the first place to do that by
the year 2035 is in energy production
by 2050 totally all right is he going to
get china to do it no we're finished
with it is he going to get china for our
final question
i'm going to join paris accord to make
china abide by
what they agreed to all right this is
about leadership gentlemen
and this first question does go to you
president trump
imagine this is your inauguration day
what will you say
in your address to america to americans
who did not
vote for you you'll each have one minute
starting with you
we have to make a country totally
successful as it was prior to the plague
coming in from china
now we're rebuilding it and we're doing
record no message of unity 4 million
jobs in a short period of time etc but i
will tell you go back
before the plague came in just before i
was getting calls from people that were
not normally people that would call me
they wanted to get together we had the
best
black unemployment numbers in the
history of our country
hispanic women asian
inuit with diplomas with no diplomas
number one in the class everybody had
the best numbers
and you know what the other side wanted
to get together they wanted to unify
success is going to bring us together we
are on the road to success
but i'm cutting taxes and he wants to
raise everybody's taxes and what a alive
new regulations and everything
he will kill it if he gets in you will
have a depression the likes of which
you've never seen this is trump's
answer about what he would explain on on
inauguration day very very sad day for
this country
all right vice president biden same
question to you what will you say during
your inaugural address to americans who
did not vote for you
i will say i'm an american president
i represent all of you whether you voted
for me or against me
and i'm going to make sure that you're
represented i'm going to give you hope
we're going to move we're going to
choose science over fiction
we're going to choose hope over fear
we're going to choose to move forward
because we have enormous opportunities
enormous opportunities to make things
better we can grow this
economy we can deal with systemic racism
and at the same time
we can make sure that our economy is
being
run and moved and motivated by clean
energy
creating millions of new jobs and that's
the fact that's what we're going to do
and i'm going to say as i said in the
beginning what
is on the ballot here is the character
of this country
decency honor respect treating people
with dignity
making sure that everyone has an even
chance and i'm going to make sure you
get that
you haven't been getting it the last
four years all right
i want to thank you both for a very
robust hour and a half wow fantastic
debate
really appreciate it president trump
former vice president joe biden
thank you to belmont university for
hosting us tonight and most of
trump is furious those watching tonight
election day
is november 3rd don't forget to vote
thank you everyone and have a great
night
let's see if there's any kind of
greeting here and with that moderator
jill biden there you see let's switch
over to c-span now
uh i do want to pay attention very very
closely to exactly what we see
wow i have never seen i think
you know even if you go back to the
obama romney
debate where the please proceed governor
thing started
i think this was even more uneven
um there is melania trump
glancing very briefly at joe biden but
essentially no recognition
uh oh my god it's so awkward with trump
and melania it's just like what is going
on
what is going i wish they would just
keep the camera on them
uh so this is how like a couple where
they like each other i guess greets
each other um trump seems to be furious
he's not even
glancing at joe biden i mean look at
look at trump
it it is it is shocking and off he goes
wow biden just waved two of and trump
didn't even acknowledge him
trump didn't even acknowledge the wave
what a triggered snowflake to borrow of
what is
a really kind of ugly term from that the
right uses i mean
not even acknowledging the wave
unbelievable
wow um
i don't think i've ever seen a debate
more
unbounce so so here's my sort of
takeaway the biden
i'm sorry the obama
um the obama romney debate in 2012 where
romney went on that rant and obama just
sat there and said
please proceed governor um that was
a really uh uneven debate
but romney did better than trump here
like i don't i'm not saying biden did
better than obama
but romney had done so much better than
trump did tonight that the
gap between them was not as big in that
debate
in 2012 i mean truly unbelievable
and um i mean just destruction
i don't even know how you pretend to
defend
uh donald trump's performance today
listen 65
000 of you join me tonight if you're
leaving
please make sure to hit the subscribe
button
on youtube so that you will be notified
when we go live like on election night
if you're watching on twitch and taking
off make sure to follow me
if you're watching on facebook make sure
to hit the like button
if you appreciated the coverage i would
really love it
if you grabbed a membership at
joinpakman.com as you can see 154 people
have signed up so far
i would love to get to 200 and we're not
talking about a lot of money we've got a
beautiful perfect coupon code
2020 now which will save you 66
if if if you've had enough i get it
we're going to open up the phone lines
though and i want to hear from
from some people uh but many many ways
to support the work we do
and memberships are are just a perfect
perfect way
so i will um i'm not going to make it a
very very late
evening but i would be glad to hear from
some of you we're going to do it via
discord
okay so i'm going to give you the
instructions for how to talk to me
go to davidpakman.com discord that's
d-i-s-c-o-r-d
um once you are there go into the
waiting lobby
and change your nickname to
location colon name so like
if your name is blanche and you're in
whitefish
montana you would put whitefish
colon blanche you understand okay
and then i will call on people um in
some sort of order i don't i don't know
exactly what kind of order but we'll
we'll talk to a few people
um and if you are heading out i really
do appreciate you joining me we we did
have a
uh we we had a record stream tonight and
i'm so glad people were interested in
what
these candidates had to say uh let's see
what's on people's minds okay
davidpakman.com
discord a lot of people waiting let me
see here um we're just going to go
it's it's hard to know exactly where to
start
but just for kicks let's start
with um a local caller johnny from
boston
johnny from boston what's going on
now boy johnny from boston
can you unmute and talk to me
uh okay johnny from boston had muted
himself
that was user error unfortunately
let's go next to uh
where are we going to go let's go to
oh my god so many people are trying to
get in here at once that i
like can't even take a call this is
crazy let's go to rob from virginia rob
from virginia please
unmute and you will be on with me as
soon as you do that
oh boy rob from virginia
um if you have to listen you do have to
listen to me through discord
because if you're listening on the
stream you're gonna experience a pretty
big delay
all right that's not working let's see
uh what else
let's go to uh mike from finland mike
from finland what's going on
mike from finland what's going on
oh boy mike from finland what is going
on
all right let's go to tally from
australia
tally from australia
kind of odd starting to wonder if the
issue's on my end quite frankly
uh let's see here tally from australia
are you with me
ah david can you hear me yes i can um
yeah so i'm from aussie and um
you know we've all been paying attention
because our fascists tend to copy your
ones
right um but uh yeah the thing i was
just thinking about
going into that is um like
he really doesn't have the momentum of
2016 does he like no
uh you know if like you were to sort of
look at what trump did in 2016
it was like but he went up against like
seven democrat
uh republicans and crushed them all on
the debate stage and then
you know went on to the final boss you
know so to speak
and i guess for this one it's just like
he's only had two debate
performances now and they've both been
um
really flat you know uh yeah but i think
tonight was that was
uh acutely disastrous for trump the
first one was sort of like he
interrupted a lot and a lot of people
didn't like it
tonight was a disaster like i don't
remember seeing probably ever in
in any debate i've covered yeah no i
agree with you i i think um
something else i've kind of been
thinking about is like you know how
there is the i guess
narrative that like joe biden's losing
his marbles or whatever yeah
yeah um the thing i'm thinking around
that is like
you do sometimes see the visual
glitching but it's not really that
distracting when like the guy next to
him is just like
like talking about low iq immigrants and
stuff yeah
like like that there i was expecting his
next line that he was going to say like
joe joe we got to secure the existence
of our people like
it was borderline it was exactly that
type you're absolutely right and
you know okay biden biden has had a
stutter for a long time
and i i i can see joe biden is not as
as uh quick as he was with paul ryan in
2012
but the difference today was just night
and day
yeah no i i definitely agree um i guess
just just to finish up because so more
people can talk and whatnot i guess
it's been very interesting watching this
from australia because i'm not sure if
you've
uh you probably don't follow australian
politics because they're pretty boring
but like
yeah i don't but mostly because i have
my hands full here
they've all gone through that same
populist thing and i just say to most
americans are watching you know
what happens in america does tend to
have a flow on effect to
um our other countries like we are
seeing um arise it's sort of like
hate groups and stuff so make good
choices guys that's all i'll say
all right i appreciate that great to
hear from our friends in
australia uh if you would like to get on
with me the place to do it
is davidpakman.com discord let's hear
from
from a few other people and i'm doing i
really am doing the best i can here
because there are so many people holding
let's go to sinai from boston
sinai from boston what's going on
sinai from boston please unmute hey how
are you can you hear me
yes i can um i thought it was a really
interesting debate i think joe biden did
a really good job way better than
last time he seemed like he was really
on it probably because he wasn't being
interrupted as much
um the meeting probably helped um i
thought it was really interesting when
like
they were talking about china and trump
was kind of saying
um that china pays for
the the taxes on the tariffs sinai i
hate to interrupt you but every half
second
your discord is is beeping um if you can
if you can uh define that that would be
really good because it's it's a big
distraction
oh when i deafen it um
oh it mutes does she need does she need
to deafen her mute guys can somebody
tell me what she needs to do
or is it plugging in headphones oh i
don't have any headphones on headphones
we don't have okay
okay you can go to the next caller then
i think you need click to talk or
if some of the moderators can help me i
will put cineback we've got to deal with
that some people you don't hear it some
people you do i don't even know what to
tell them
they've got to turn off their
notification i don't know we've got to
set that at the server level please
uh somebody help me because i am i am
like uh
i am drowning without a paddle here
let's go to
um dear god everything going on
let's go to fernando from texas fernando
what's going on
hey um yeah no the debate was
absolutely it was not what i was
expecting no
me neither me neither yeah it was
especially that comment about uh iq
yeah oh boy i mean it kind of
shows who he is in a sense yeah
yeah it's gonna be i'm an immigrant so
i've uh
i guess a deeper connection to that than
most
voters but it's i don't well
we've seen that in the past four years
it's not like some is something
completely new or anything like that no
listen i mean trump shouting out about
low iq hispanics during a debate is sort
of the logical culmination of the dog
whistling red meat we've seen for the
last five years that
it's just it's exactly what you would
expect
yeah it's been crazy honestly i biden
did a lot better
than i'd hoped he would do especially
with the muting i think that helped
he did fantastic points across it there
were there were i mean
there were mic drops there were kill
shots uh biden you know i i i
he could he could be charged with murder
for what happened tonight and i hope
he's not
yeah yeah no but
thanks so much for covering here as well
because it was
it was good to get some of that extra
info in about especially like the
crime bill and because people like trump
they just like to talk very loud
yeah and talk over the truth so to speak
it was very well done all right my
friend thank you i am being told
uh make sure to set your status to do
not disturb
so that we don't hear the constant
blinging of people's discords
we are taking calls on discord
davidpakman.com
slash discord is the place
davidpakman.com
discord let's go to joe from
massachusetts next
oh wow i wasn't expecting to be called
um i i thought this wasn't
as like good for biden as um the first
one
really the kind of undecided voters who
are like
i imagine any undecided voter kind of
wants to like trump this almost brings
them back a little
um there's one line in there that he's
now thrown out a few times and that was
like a
talking point about like the first time
he's heard blm they're saying pigs in a
blanket fry them like bacon so the whole
movement's bad
yeah i think it'd be very interesting if
we were to apply that rule to his
movement of his supporters at his
rallies or
unite the right rallies or even or even
going from trump like trump's early
statement about mexican rapists like if
we're judging everybody by the first
thing we hear about them you know
well he brought it back you know he
brought out that old classic this time
so i'm just quite surprised to hear
yeah i mean i understand what you're
saying i think this was good for biden i
think
i think it was good for biden i i do
disagree with you but respectfully and
with peace and love
yeah no i mean i still i just think that
the kind of people who wanted to vote
for trump but were like oh he was too
crazy the first one
this might have reeled them back in a
little but i just think the implosion
outweighs him
yeah yeah no i think the implosion
outweighs it uh but i appreciate your
take
thank you all right very good and
remember guys in order to prevent that
really annoying uh blinging constantly
set your
discord to do not disturb do not disturb
is exactly exactly what we
what we want uh let's see who else we've
got here
there's a 10 different people named sam
who are holding
let's go to sergio from mexico
sergio como estas
sergio
that's too bad i was looking forward to
speaking with him
uh let's go to solon from
worcester massachusetts hi there david
can you hear me
i can hear you loud and clear oh it was
so nice to talk with you i
uh i have headphones on i recommend
other people do that as well
pristine um so i uh i was watching
the uh the debate and i noticed that
there wasn't much interruption
between uh the the candidates
and i'm wondering what what do you
attribute to that was do you think
kristen welker talked to them beforehand
and
said hey you know guys knock it off that
really wasn't cool with christmas no no
no
i think i think that um trump trump has
been
they've been begging trump not to
interrupt and of course they had the
muting during the first two minutes
each and i think trump just actually
paid attention
and really limited his interruption only
towards the last 40 or so minutes
trump couldn't take it but remember guys
the mics were not muted during the
last 11 minutes of each segment and so i
think trump just
you know he he accepted what his
advisors were telling him which was the
interruption was really bad during the
first debate
and what do you make of that last uh
that last image that we saw of him
walking away
while biden was waving emblematic of the
entire thing i mean just you know an
angry
he doesn't you know he barely reacts to
his wife approaching him
biden waves and trump just turns and
walks away it's just it's
this is what it is this is what it is
it's it's this is trump and
you can either vote for it or you can
vote for something else uh first time
caller i recommend people
join the membership program i love your
show david
yes absolutely and speaking of which
before i get to the next caller let me
just update
we have just very powerfully jumped to
190 new members at jointpakman.com
we're only 10 away that's 0.03 percent
of the people watching right now can you
imagine that
uh let's let's do it let's do it all
right let's see who else we've got
holding here
um i'm trying to get sort of a
geographically diverse
sampling um where are we going to go
next
let's go to um
what is going on here i'm having some
trouble
parsing some of these names let's go to
uh let's go to ben from vancouver ben
what's going on
hey um i was just watching the debate
and like everybody else was uh and i
actually
noticed a very big divide in
partisanship in america compared to what
we have in canada
yes it seems that the politicians
actually
uh try to work against each other rather
than working with each other
and it was very clear tonight um as
donald trump uh decided against uh
interrupting people
as often as he would have normally yes
uh you could see
more of his uh policies and
his true nature i guess you could say i
don't think i really heard it that's
interesting you say that
i don't think i heard a single real
policy from trump
um i think he talked about what he would
do he
did i think trump talked about talking
about policy
trump talked a lot about if you re-elect
him
he will then propose policy which for me
is not so good
yeah it definitely isn't because uh that
can also be seen as
holding the american people hostage
right yeah um
it seems that when he does that though
uh a lot of people don't understand
especially when he makes comments along
the lines of uh
biden didn't do anything for the eight
years that he was vice president
right people uh seem to not understand
how
even me as a canadian i feel like i have
a better understanding of the american
political system than a lot of people do
watching it um i would not be surprised
i did say
um they didn't have the senate and
without the senate it
is extremely hard to pass legislation as
you've seen
with nancy pelosi passing bill after
bill and it's just sitting on
mcconnell's desk right
which is why the importance of democrats
taking the senate is right up there with
taking
place yeah exactly i would actually put
it uh just
as important maybe so uh
not even like i mean i think from the
standpoint of repairing relationships
that's really something the president
does
so i think that that is very important
but legislatively i agree with you it's
just as important yeah
okay i'll give it over to somebody else
all right my friend of vancouver canada
checking in there
very very much love it let's go next to
um we are going to go to
kim from mcdonough somewhere i can't
tell where kim where are you from
kim you can go ahead and unmute yourself
then i'll be able to hear you
kim from mcdonough somewhere
hello
all right we're going to move on from
kim there uh let's go to
julie from burlingame california
where's burlingame julie um can you hear
me
i can hear you i can hear you but you've
got gotta you've gotta mute the stream
in the background that's playing you
gotta listen to me through discord
tell it okay i'm back here i'm
i'm so sorry i'm i'm a gen xer and i'm
still learning how to use discord
you're doing great okay oh no i'm still
so let me ask you this
where is my voice coming out of right
now is it coming out of a computer
somewhere else in the room
no my phone that's bizarre
are you watching the stream and on
discord on the phone is that what's
going on
that's probably what i think you got to
close or pause the stream
there we go beautiful is it better now
it's it's all set so what's going on
what's on your mind today
no it's still going on sorry i'm gonna
have to i'm gonna have to mute you i'm
sorry
you gotta that that we just can't do
that because it's it's it's literally i
don't wanna be rude but it's impossible
to uh
speak when that's going on it's um it's
a
an oral thing a-u-r-a-l
uh let's go next to brian from iowa
let's go to the heartland brian from
iowa what's going on with you
brian from iowa you can unmute yourself
and talk
brian from iowa you have one last chance
to unmute yourself and talk
and i guess that's not happening wow
that's really too bad
let's go to corey from california let's
go
me me mimi bryant
yes hello um hi oh that worked
how are you i'm good thank you so it
sounds like you also have the stream
going in the background
i don't have the stream oh you don't
okay all right very good very good
okay um my question was uh
i actually thought trump was very uh and
not to say that i agree with anything
i still think he's an idiot but um he
was very poised
tonight and do you think that'll
actually swayed the people that might
have been like you his last debate was
icky
into maybe wanting to support now
it's possible i mean so here's the thing
it's when when you watch a debate like
this it's not just
voters move from one candidate to the
other it's most people don't move at all
and then some people will move from one
candidate to the other and then some
will move in the opposite direction
and while i think there is no question
that there are some people who wanted to
vote for trump but needed to sort of
feel like he could behave normally and i
don't think he did but he was more
normal than the first debate
he probably will secure a few votes
there um
but with the with joe biden's
performance i think the net benefit is
the biden here
okay yeah i was a little nervous in the
beginning because he was very put
together
yeah wait you're saying trump was i
found biden in the beginning in the
beginning i was almost nervous i was
like oh he was prepped
like really prepped then he lost it then
he went off yeah he completely lost it
completely lost it yeah is someone else
in the room with you laughing
oh i'm sorry that would be my fiancee oh
okay all right i was trying to
understand because it sort of sounds
like my own voice but it's someone else
no that's my fiance yes well uh so
is the when it when is the wedding oh
well yeah well with covid we're
we're years out right now oh okay we're
nowhere near there
very good all right well i appreciate
the uh the contact
thank you thank you for having me take
care very nice um
okay that we're hearing from some nice
people when they can get themselves
unmuted
let's go to um let's go to samantha b
samantha b is on next
hey david can you hear me because i'm a
computer now instead of my
phone uh i can hear you yeah
so now you're cutting out though
i was so i did my absolutely ballot in
texas
hello all right we can't do it it's it's
you know sometimes discord goes
perfectly but it's just
not working well and and that was just
completely on the caller's end that was
not on my end
um where else are we going to go
uh let's go to renee from baton rouge
louisiana
renee from baton rouge louisiana
renee
renee i can hear background noise so you
must be there
i hear a door
renee you're on right now
oh can you hear me yeah
okay uh i i i uh so i'm from louisiana
and uh i just think it's a little uh
like i i obviously feel one way about
trump as seeing as i watch your show
i have some family members who think
he's the greatest president ever and
just the more and more time goes by and
the more i see especially
celebrities endorsing him i'm just
absolutely baffled by
how anyone can see him talk the way that
he does and
and still support him i just i'm i don't
even really have a question it's just
you know i'm just confused honestly yeah
me too but i would i mean you'd have to
ask them i don't understand it either
yeah and and i i just i just want to
thank you because i you know
keep keeping keep the way you keep track
of everything and
i i just really appreciate because i
know it's got to take a toll on you to
keep track of all the insane stuff that
that he says every day and
so i i thank you for doing the legwork i
suppose
thank you i appreciate the uh the the
kind words
thank you all right very good there's
renee
from baton rouge let's go next
to uh where are we going
it's very hard to know
let's go to da lana del rique
lana del rique you are on
lana del rique you are on right now
all right can you hear me yes i barely
can but i can
perfect um so i'm from colorado i didn't
figure out how to change my nickname
on there to enrique from colorado all
right anyway
um damn i had so much to say now that
i'm on i'm all nervous
um well let me talk you through it where
in colorado are you calling from
northeastern colorado which is the whole
red part of colorado is that near
colorado springs or that's northwest
north uh colorado springs would be more
like southern
mid-south okay because that's like the
evangelical
capital of the country or something
right basically
yeah yeah out here in northeastern it's
all like the rural areas
all about agriculture how rural is it
like how close is your grocery store
oh grocery store is not too bad it's
less than a mile away
it's more like uh superstore wise like
i'm about an hour and a half from denver
um 45 minutes from greeley
so if you have to go to like a target
how far is that
45 minutes will be the shortest my god
and then how do you pronounce the word
rural
rural rural okay interesting
all right it sounds like you're typing
up a storm there so i'm going to let you
go but if you remember your
question i'd love to hear from you again
let's go next to grace from michigan
if possible
i um i actually thought that like
this debate there was a lot more policy
talk
but part of the problem i think is
is that there's this consensus among
conservatives
that biden isn't competent and he can't
speak and i think he did a really good
job
of being eloquent and kind of
keeping it together more so than they
claim he hasn't in the past
but i just don't think that anything
that is going to be said or don
is really going to sway anyone on the
right
um and you would hope it would sway
people in the middle
but i just don't know how you could be
torn between the two
like that i don't either and you know we
actually we know we know a lot about
undecideds undecideds tend to be younger
center-right and don't really know stuff
like they don't really pay much
attention that's the demographic of the
people that are undecided
i think the the effect of tonight's
debate is less about
affecting them it's more about 45
of the country didn't vote in the last
presidential election
and there's tens of millions of people
there who if they voted would vote for
biden
and hopefully they get activated that's
that's i think
my approach yeah and we're having
significant voter turnout which
which like i you know me and some
friends were talking about this the
other day
whenever there's been a huge amount of
turnout
they usually swing democrat so my hope
is
we can keep our fingers crossed and
we'll pull ahead in the polls and that's
what it looks like right now
but i mean this happened last election
they kind of screwed us over
as far as the electoral electoral
college goes because
hillary won the popular vote so it's
just kind of like
okay well we'll just hold our breath but
i'm kind of glad
you know he did not keep his composure
he got to the end
and he he started losing that he lost
and
i think it's important to watch these
debates i think a lot of people want to
sit by
and not see it but i think you have to
be aware of what's going on because
otherwise
you sit too comfortably in your own
reality
and you can't really see the perspective
of what's actually going on and how
terrifying
um another four years of trump could be
um so i think it's important to watch
these debates just to be
informed even though it's hard to watch
completely agree with you
completely you know burying your head in
the sand is not going to accomplish uh
too too much
uh how rural is where you live in
michigan
oh i live in mount pleasant michigan
we have central university here so it's
not
i've done black lives matter protests
like i've actually helped organize them
and get people together in my town
because people just weren't doing it
over
the summer um but we have like
so it's a weird mix so you have all the
liberal
college students but then you have
very very conservative people in our
town
so i when i did the black lives matter
protest
i personally received death threats um
we would stand out on
the street corner and i mean it would be
like several cars would drive by
and we would get blurs thrown at us the
middle finger
um i frequently see trump flaps
oh boy you're cutting out a little bit
and it sounds like there's a dog barking
in the background is that right
um while the internet's bad here i live
on
in the dorms so got it listen before i
let you go
do you consider a hot dog a sandwich
um no you don't okay that's fair
that's fair all right all right okay
thanks very much i appreciate the uh
appreciate the call uh we are taking
calls through
discord the uh address is
davidpakman.com
discord um let's take a couple more
but before i do that just to update
people
we have now brought in 225
new website members this evening not a
record but a beautiful
beautiful number um let's see
where else we can go what looks
interesting
and i i apologize i can't possibly get
to everybody
but i'm trying let's go to jocelyn from
virginia
jocelyn from virginia how are you
jocelyn from virginia you're on live
and last opportunity for jocelyn from
virginia
all right no jocelyn from virginia let's
see who else we've got um
how about i don't know let's go to
lyanna lyanna what's going on
lyanna you can unmute yourself and then
you will be talking to me and going
three times for lyanna
hey hello
oh my god hello did you drop your phone
hello did you drop your phone
hello liana sorry i threw my phone
oh you're british how are you doing
good are you calling from the uk right
now
hello no i'm not getting it to work
properly sorry
can you hear me right now baby you're
from isn't it four in the morning in
london i
am i was all ready to go to bed and then
i watched that debate
and now i'm all totally awake wow
um well what what can i do for you
hmm
is the kebab shop a proper dinner in
your mind
all right well that's not working super
well unfortunately
um dear god what a night
let's try i don't know
this let's stick with the uk though um
let's go to penny from the uk
penny are you in the uk is it 4 am there
penny from the uk you're on live
okay all right guys listen it's getting
laid um i know that everybody i didn't
go to would have had perfect connections
i know i'm gonna get 100 emails about
how
you know everybody was just completely
ready um unfortunately
uh we're gonna have to call it there
because it's been a very very long day i
do want to thank the 226 people who
signed up on my website
joinedpakman.com um please remember
i as you head out subscribe free on
youtube
follow free on twitch like free on
facebook these platforms
are our livelihood what a debate tonight
we are going to be played out with a new
very special music video
as well as the latest song from joseph
woodward thanks to everybody for
joining me we will be back very very
soon
of the nationally syndicated radio and
tv
program the david pacman show
and i wanted to talk to david pakman he
is a beta
david pacman he is a beta
male david pacman he is
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah male
1
they think and act like a woman they are
emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but
whoa whoa jesse well we gotta that's a
lot
that's a lot hang on agree with
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman a beta
male died
but not doesn't because he's a logical
thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pakman
he is a baby
david pacman he
[Music]
pacman he is a beta male
1 he gave it pacman
he is
pacman he is a baby
david you're not here to communicate i
really appreciate you coming on i'm
going to let you go it's a waste of time
to talk to you
we're not communicating you're actually
like because you're asking bizarre
questions you're acting like an
idiot and you're wasting my time i
appreciate that
all right thanks for coming goodbye
goodbye
[Music]
it doesn't even come